foreign
[Music]
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem
so do you think you have what it takes
to compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
presentation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
Yana Promenade first world championship
victory in game two this has to be such
an amazing feeling
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame whoa what have you
seen this move before what's happening
he has to definitely find the momentum
and recompose himself
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
foreign
of the Saint Regis Hotel in Astana
Kazakhstan where exactly 12 minutes from
now at 3 pm local time world number two
janapomnishi and world number three ding
liren will commence the third Match Game
of the 2023 fide World Championship
welcome ladies and gentlemen to
chess.com's coverage of the world
championship I'm your host Grandmaster
Daniel nariditsky alongside me today of
course Grandmaster Anish gearing and
someone's crashing the party Grandmaster
David Howell a pleasure to have you in
the studio
yeah thank you Dania and thank you Anish
it's a pleasure to be here thanks for
letting me gay crash I've been watching
the first two days from afar and I'm
hoping for more exciting chess today
anytime David Anish we had a rest day
yesterday I don't know about you I
really needed that recipe I'm feeling
energized how are you feeling are you
pumped for the third day of action
yeah feeling ready and refreshed and so
do the players I think today is an
important day uh what strategy Will
Young choose with the white pieces will
he be satisfied with his uh one point
lead or will he go for more we'll see
we will see indeed let's have a look at
the scoreboard and how the match has
gone so far the first game ended in a
Topsy Turvy draw Jan had ding on the
Rope sting escaped and then of course
that shocking second game where Jana
pomnushi scores his first victory in a
world championship match he defeats
dingly Ren in resounding fashion with
the black pieces despite tingly rand's
opening trickery that four H3 move
fortunately it did not work David what a
game that was and what a challenge ding
now faces as he is staring down the
barrel of not only a one point deficit
but he also has to play Black in this
game
yeah we already knew that Ding wasn't uh
quite feeling himself but uh what a
heartbreaking that defeat would have
been on game two as well the rest day
must have come at an opportune moment he
would have uh hopefully been able to
switch off being able to think about
other things and actually it might be a
blessing having black in this next game
he can just react and go with the flow
but of course if Yan is able to put some
pressure on
things might get tricky so we'll see
it's still early days in the match I'm
hoping that Ding is able to show his
best form
that's a good point there David actually
that uh I didn't think about that of
course the the problem with playing with
the black pieces is that you cannot uh
Force an advantage from the opening you
cannot try and come back on demand but
maybe you're right maybe that's not what
you need maybe you need uh to have a day
without pressure just to steady that
ship so in that sense not not the worst
color pairing there for ding but we'll
see Young's looking by the way really
fresh as I can really see him arriving
at the board
he most certainly is and we hope dingley
Ren is going to look fresh because he
has his work caught out for him and
speaking of dingley renin his
psychological mindset obviously ding
will have to arrive with a positive
mindset with a strong mindset and our
very own D-Day Master Mike Klein is
doing some amazing work Mike offers his
insights on how ding is going to handle
the psychological challenges that await
him in this game Let's listen in
going into round three and what we all
want to know is what style of play will
ding Loren choose he played a little bit
more solidly in game one and although he
was pressured he held the draw but in
game two he almost seemed to try to
mimic his new Bromance partner Richard
Rapport by playing H3 on move four very
offbeat move and then castling on
opposite sides but he went down in
flames losing his white in only 30 moves
so will he go back to his traditional
more solid style or will he keep playing
like the Romanian Grand Master we shall
see now remember back to 2021 Yan
napomnishi abandoned his more aggressive
style he tried to bore Magnus as or his
words not mine that didn't work out at
all so changing Styles in 2021 didn't
work changing Styles in 2023 not working
so far for ding Loren we will see if he
goes back to his more solid style as
black as he enters this third game also
keep in mind that sometimes once you get
one loss a runaway train happens again
I'm speaking back to 2021 where Jan
played just fine for about five rounds
well once he suffered his first loss
then came 2-3 and then ultimately his
fourth so ding definitely needs to stop
the bleeding we will see if he's able to
do that this is mycline for chess.com at
the feed a world championship in Astana
Kazakhstan
thanks Mike fantastic insights as usual
and as we have a look at Ding and nepo's
head to head obviously it's important
for ding not to catastrophize you don't
want to change your style too much
because your record with Napo is still
pretty decent most games have still
ended in a draw and we have talked from
the very very start about how
unbelievably evenly matched these
players are whether you look at their
age their classical rating seven points
separate that or even their classical
and Rapid head to head so David I think
the ding could use that as a positive
the fact that yeah he lost a game but in
the grand scheme of things they're still
very evenly matched
yeah exactly on paper it's uh basically
a coin toss and despite the fact his
head to head is slightly inferior
compared to nepo uh he needs to take
maybe inspiration from last year where
Magnus was the one who actually was down
in the head-to-head against napoleonishi
and managed to turn it around we all
know what happened there so yeah he
needs to not adapt too much not change
his style not panic yet it's still early
days and he is the slightly younger
player maybe it's slightly more
energetic in those closing stages he
just needs to stay in this match for now
yeah the head-to-head uh is one thing I
think the fact that he's trailing the
match that's another issue that Ding is
facing a big issue and if you don't want
to see a one-sided match as Mike planner
suggested we have seen some of those in
history the match of course the last
match of uh Magnus against Yan but also
there are other cases where things were
rather one-sided the chromic are not
match surprisingly was okay also quite
equal when it came to their individual
matchup Head to Head rating and all that
but that match somehow spiraled out of
control a loss by you know with white
Pieces by kramnik one more loss with
white Pieces by kramnik and it was all
pretty much over so um there is some
danger there but hopefully ding will
mount a comeback at some point
we will see and obviously the pressure
on these players is unimaginable and
it's unimaginable not only because the
title of world champion is at stake but
also at stake is of course a massive
prize Well there are two million euros
at stake with 1.2 of them going to the
champion and a pretty nice sum of 800
000 Euros I'll take it if he does if the
loser doesn't want it uh going to the
runner-up and of course the champion
also defends uh their title at the next
few day world championship they get to
defend their title so the pressure on
these players David I mean I was feeling
nervous as a commentator before round
one and before the show Anish told me
okay you're feeling nervous just put
yourself in ding shoes or nepo shoes for
just a second
yeah I get nervous playing friendly
Blitz Games down the pub but uh I can't
imagine uh the level of pressure that
these uh guys are under it did show I
must say in ding's first couple of games
and it might have been vital that Yan
has been here before he was probably
feeling the same
um last year so much at stake of course
but uh the players need to focus they
need to get that out of their minds uh
for now and uh here we do see ding
sitting at the board and a handshake
incoming
it's ready to get the game going indeed
and the pressure uh that is something
that no one is immune to even Magnus
Carlson his first world championship
match against Christian and if you
remember that first game with the black
pieces where he played the karokan after
one E4 he touched that c pawn and the
pawn just fell onto the board his hands
were trembling as he dropped the C Pawn
uh on on the board and not only that he
placed it on C6 we should have placed it
on C5 of course played the Sicilian
instead was a very nervous game for
Magnus and
um obviously anybody who is facing this
such a challenge with so much at stake
and he's going he's going to to feel the
heat and um yeah ding has been suffering
from that but maybe now he's you know
the worst is behind him he already lost
the game maybe he'll feel somewhat of
relief and finally we'll be able to
place this kind of game and um you know
get get off to a
so a good start of round three
well it seems to me that the three
minutes before the start of the game it
might be the most nerve-wracking time
for the Players Once the game starts
they kind of get into their groove but
we will put these three minutes to very
good use and we'll remind you of the
format for the world championship if
you're just joining us the scoring is
very standard there's one point assigned
to the winner and uh half a point for a
draw if you lose you get zero points in
contrast to the previous World
Championship players swap colors each
game so no one has consecutive white or
consecutive black a draw cannot be
offered by move 40 although a draw can
be uh agreed before move 40 through
three-time repetition first to seven and
a half points wins the championship also
known as best of 14 and if the match is
tied 7-7 there will be a rapid
tiebreaker but we'll cross that bridge
if we get there the time control for the
classical portion is anything but rapid
it is one of the slowest and most
methodical time controls that we have
anywhere in any tournament or match two
hours for the first 40 moves then an
hour added after move 40 and then after
move 60 another 15 minutes added to the
players clock and finally after move 60
a 30 second increment is established in
order to avoid the craziest of time
scrambles but we are very far away from
move 60 we haven't had move one yet and
this is that time these are the 60
seconds David I'm going to ask you first
are we gonna see one E4 we're gonna see
one H3 I mean if ding is playing H3 on
move four why not playing on move two
remove one
I would love to see it Dania one H3 um
who knows I think there's a ceremonial
first move who knows what uh the
kind of guest will play on move one but
I do think we'll see Yan go for the
Spanish go for something he's uh tried
before I don't think he's gonna take too
much risk in the opening he just wants
to achieve a playable position and put
in under some pressure so
unfortunately I don't think we'll see
any surprises any fireworks how about
your niche yeah no H3 there I think the
famous astronaut from Kazakhstan is
going to execute the first move and I
think he will go for space and that that
will be something in the center one E4
uh the most likely young says do
whatever you like actually so we'll see
we'll see what happens so whatever you
like they keep see what you did there I
see yeah back and forth there
oh
[Laughter]
keep on
D4 that is
all right that doesn't mean Yano play D4
no no not at all and I think Yan wants
to keep these extra extra few seconds in
reserve not to give it away to ding keep
him guessing uh guess one E4 is the more
likely one but we'll see
okay anticipation here
Moment of Truth what will he play
and Shake walk is starting and now is
the time game three ladies and gentlemen
of the world championship is upon us oh
the first move has been made and it is
in fact E4 oh my lands
wow D4 I'm all surprise David
what do you make this yeah I I mean I'm
a big fan I've got to say uh despite the
fact he started with 184 in the first
game despite the fact he got an
advantage it's always nice to kind of
keep your opponent on their toes keep
them guessing
and yeah I'll be fascinated to see
ding's response I think we'll be able to
tell a lot about ding's mindset uh by
how he reacts to this first small
surprise remember last World
Championship Match as well Jan was
mostly playing E4 no d4s at all uh first
surprise first uh kind of sign of mind
game finish
yeah no surprise indeed I mean I if I
thought about this one C for perhaps one
D4 is the move the young plays the least
he started playing it a lot recently he
played the Catalan I think he suffered a
lot on the black side of the castle on
in the world championship match and then
later on in the candidates as well he
had to explore a lot of it and so he
adopted the Catalan with the white
pieces he also tried various other
things in some rapid games I remember
some nimso attempts where he tried to go
for let's explore the positions I don't
like ding's body language I don't like
I mean okay come on we are surprised we
are commentators but you should be ready
just just show more confidence sit there
a bit more firmly make you move a bit
faster but Knight F6 finally happened
might have six on the board and of
course Jan controls the center with C4
and ding responds with E6 so far
following the opening from the previous
game now Jan uh Anish as you pointed out
has shown a predilection or the Catalan
he's played it a lot in the rapid Chess
Championship in fact he basically played
exclusively the Catalan so I mean David
I think you'll co-sign anisha's point
that there's no way the ding this didn't
even enter his radar Knight C3 by the
way is on the board
yeah um D4 after all is one of the two
most popular first moves so he would
have spent some time dedicated some time
preparing this Ding and yeah I was kind
of same expecting the Catalan as well
once we saw D4 but it does make sense
ding is a Catalan expert himself with
the white pieces so why not at least ask
a different question maybe take him out
of a comfort zone and uh there we go
it's a Queen's Gambit declined and uh no
names are Indian a small surprise but I
like ding's response here very solid
stuff he'll get a position out of the
opening very playable position and
no matter whether he's slightly worse no
matter whether he's slightly cramped
he's alive and um okay Bishop G5 who do
you think surprised who more with this
opening
yeah I think David uh this is a very
common
um
common way to play nowadays because
that's the theory in the names of Indian
is expanding more and more there's much
um many more forcing lines the black has
to be aware of in the name so there is
the queen C2 name so there is the F3
there is the E3 names of this and the
Knight actually there's all sorts of
different nimsos and the theory is
expanding and why it's finding more and
more forcing attempts and at some point
black realized that they could get rid
of all this these headaches if they just
learn the move 3d5 instead and go for
this very solid Carlsbad structure now
the problem is the downside of that is
that this particular version of the
Carlsbad is not too favorable for black
as the C8 Bishop will not be able to get
out neither 25 nor to G4 that's why it's
going to go E3 fold by Bishop D3 or
queen C2 and then with this bishop on C8
it will be a problem piece for a while
and this version of Carlsbad is known to
be somewhat passive for black but as
black tried to get rid of all these
nymphs or headaches they have gone
deeper and deeper into this uh lines and
try to devise ways to attempt to
equalize now things started with the
move C6 not Bishop E7 which suggests
suggests that he might go for Bishop F5
after E3 this is another big system
let's see now what moves he makes
yeah moving just yet
I was gonna say sorry Bishop 5 does lead
some forcing lines but no
okay choosing something else very quick
stop as you say down here H6 is this in
either results on the board
yeah is this in either of your
repertoires I must admit I've only
looked briefly at these Pawn structures
in general but uh
yeah not too sure on on the specifics if
something I'll have yeah I
I
please yeah I was going to defer to
Anisha because I played this with white
sparingly a couple times Carlsbad
structure has been around really since
the early 20th century I want to say you
know the time of Akiba Rubenstein and
you know all of those classical Masters
so it's not a new structure the
structure is very well understood but
even within a very old structure you
could essentially have you know new wine
in Old bottles you could have new ideas
introduced to a line that has been known
for over a hundred years so Anish I
defer completely to you all I really
know is that white as a choice of where
to develop the G1 Knight you could
develop it to F3 or you could develop it
to E2 after Bishop D3 and essentially
prepare the very ambitious F3 E4 Pawn
break is that a good summary of whites
two overarching plans
yeah I would agree with you certainly so
the the two big plans that we know in
the Carlsbad uh one more commonly used
with the Knight on F3 that's the
minority attack on the queen side that's
where you go for Rook B1 B4 B5 try to
take on C6 and create a weakness on the
C6 uh square that that weak Pawn the
other common plan is indeed Bishop
between ig2 and then you uh more likely
than not follow with eventual F3 and E4
going for the center the both winning
plan then black and their turn very
often after F3 tries to
generate some counter play with either
remove C5 or the move nowadays more
common uh approach also is B5 very uh
interesting and unusual way to fling I
should also mention in small detail the
thing has already played H6 and it is uh
one of the two ways of playing nowadays
with or without these things but back in
the day the traditional way of playing
the Carlsbad it was supposed to be when
I was growing up as a kid I was supposed
to be that H6 is an accurate because
black was going for this Knight bt7
Knight f8 Knight G6 plan and then with
the pawn H6 uh White could go Bishop D3
Queen C2 and prevent that Knight G6 jump
so this was some kind of old wisdom but
the modern engines uh they've discovered
that it's not so simple and besides this
plant black has many others and H6 could
also certainly be a useful move now Jan
is taking his time and it is already an
important important juncture Bishop D3
or queen C2 first the differences are
very very subtle
um you know black has different uh ideas
besides this Knight to f8 there's also
Knight H5 idea but Jan goes Bishop
probably the more Universal move I
suspect the bishop anyway has to land on
D3 while the queen could stay on D1 in
many of these variations
and I'm taking notes a niche uh this is
an opportunity for a free opening
masterclass thank you and uh doing ding
Castle so here I guess is the juncture
which plan does he go for which set up
and uh Jan do you think you'll have
expected this at all uh has ding been
playing this Queen's Gambit declined uh
from time to time he's played it against
me actually in the rapid game uh he used
to play in the Nim so much more often
but I I remember one time in one of
these uh Champion store online Rapids
I've prepared some nimso against Dink
and I played Knight C3 on move 3 and
Dean played D5 against me at the time
and then I remember he also played that
against ragnananda
uh in that that was a champion store
event that Ding actually won in the end
uh if you remember he beat Prague in the
final and for me the so many Champion
store events I forget which one is which
but that was one the ding one and um so
he's been spotted uh playing the system
before and so Jan has certainly prepared
it but it is even if you prepare it's
very confusing all sorts of move orders
because already for example Castle first
is not a given I believe 957 first is uh
played very often as well because there
are plans where you go for Knight H5 you
trade the dark Square Bishops then you
go for Knight B6 Bishop out from C8 and
Newcastle long if white also Castle is
locked so there are plans with long
cards like as well so Castle is actually
somewhat committal uh but sometimes
black knight from B8 has uh heads to A6
after A5 I can go to A6 keeping the
diagram of the bishop open and the
Knight eventually anyway yc7 gets back
into the center often to E6 so uh so
many subtleties and I think Janis uh he
has looked at this but uh these move
orders are confusing him and I think
he's trying to remember what setup he is
gone he's going for Forza Knight F3 here
or 92 or queen C2 first uh very
confusing stuff even if you look at it
and the main point is that even even if
uh you have looked at something prepared
something it is not so forcing both
sides have uh many many options and uh
plays far from being forced so I suspect
we get a long strategic game and
theoretical preparation do not play a
big role here
well your point is very well taken Anish
I think some people when they look at
Yan as he took a couple of minutes
before playing indeed the move Queen to
C2 retaining maximum flexibility hasn't
decided where to develop his Knight a
lot of people they think either he
expects it or he doesn't expect it but
there is kind of a middle ground a lot
of openings you know ding might have
played a couple of times so they were on
his radar but perhaps he didn't expect
them uh quite as much as he did some
other openings so he might remember some
general ideas he might remember for
example where he chose to develop the
knight from G1 but David I think it's
always so important to emphasize that
these players are human he might have
forgotten for example wait did I really
decide to develop my knight to F3 before
my queen of C2 or was it after by Queen
of C2 there's so much that these players
have to remember it's totally natural
for them to spend a couple of minutes to
make sure that their head is screwed on
right
yeah exactly despite the fact these
players will have been in preparation
mode for months uh they can't check
everything and they can't uh always have
checked everything recently so even if
Jan maybe hasn't looked at this exact
position or this variation in the last
uh well in the recent future then for
sure he'll have ideas in mind for later
on and like you say it takes time to
figure out the move orders he did spend
a couple of minutes there Jan I think
it's quite characteristic of him to at
least pause uh then make a quick Snappy
decision and ding he also doesn't know
whether Yan is in preparation or whether
he's kind of freestyling at this point
and I noticed Jan was getting up there
ding he's been sitting at the board
working things out and uh I would be
expecting him now after a minute or two
to kind of echo Yan to play quickly a
bunch of ideas here Anish like you say
try to develop the uh black V8 Knight
there are also some ideas of moving this
Knight out the way I'm not sure if in
this exact position just to try and uh
get the dark Square Bishops off black
could end up slightly cramped if he's
not careful so a trade of one set of
minor pieces would make some sense here
yeah and there is also this new uh
trendy plan so the usual way of trading
the Bishops is Knight H5 uh or if
possible 94 but here I think it's not
possible that just too many captures
there was uh in the end but there is
also this idea of Knight to E8 here I
wonder if I'm not going to be able to
take on E7 and on D5 in this particular
position
but I don't actually think I know this
line Anish C takes D5 I think there's a
rook sack where black goes CD Queen C8
and Knight C6
interesting
yeah yeah Queen takes
wait and I get trapped
Queen before first queen before first
before here check and
this looks scary right
yeah very very massive stuff but Dean
has already played the more traditional
uh approach rookie 8 and he's keeping
that Knight on B8 for now I think indeed
he might be going towards the A6 I've
seen a lot of recent games where they go
A5 Knight A6 and I think that might well
be the plan for ding now after okay I
think Young
will most likely go for Knight E2
because Knight F3 can be met with Knight
E4
which often solves many of Black's
problems
yeah you trade off at least a set of
minor pieces maybe even two uh with this
very strong Knight on e4 now
I like it uh from ding not releasing the
tension too soon
rookie eight very flexible and this I
guess is the moment that you were both
mentioning the Moment of Truth does
white kind of put the Knight 22 I just
wait to get attempts to Castle queenside
in some variations
uh I'm kind of hoping for something
along these lines in the near future
just uh kind of he's had he's had a good
experience with opposite side castling
Jan already wants this uh wants this
match
but okay not E2 and yeah more typical
plans here
wait it's going to Castle kingside most
likely
yeah this is the old but vinic plan I've
seen some games from the 30s and 40s you
know Batman and Karis uh where before
Black's counter play ideas were well
known white witch's castle play F3 play
E4 E5 F4 F5 and just one zero and those
are the golden you know the golden age
when you know you could study a line
better than your opponent and you could
just crush the best players in the world
with a typical planned game after game
of Niche unfortunately I think those
days are over but the plan of F3 as far
as I know remains extremely legitimate
and uh very very dangerous
and certainly F3 is uh a way to play
it's no longer the only way to play
because black has devised different
solutions for this F3 E4 E5 uh you know
idea of rolling across the board as I
mentioned after F3 always C5 comes into
consideration it's a typical idea in
this Pawn structure that C5 right now
would just create a isolated weak
isolated D5 Pawn but after F3 C5 if you
then capture then the E3 Pawn is also
very weak and very soft so it's sort of
a well known wisdom that you go C6 and
after F3 equals C5 in many of these
positions and as I mentioned earlier
another very common idea is this B5 B4
kicking the Knight away from the center
and then after E4 happens at some point
black takes D takes E4 and uh starts
targeting the central pawns for example
after fe4 sometimes you can play Move
Like Bishop G4 hitting the Knight on E2
then D4 Pawn is already kind of under
attack so it is or after d for fe4 there
is Knight G4 jump very often where you
are trading a pair of Bishops and Knight
is heading to E3 so lots of counter play
ideas have been in indeed uh devised by
now you no longer can just play F3 E4
and roll over and and so there there are
many different uh plans here ding is
taking his time I this position is a
huge huge tabia you cannot be surprised
here so far Jan has played all the main
uh moves so all all the standard moves
and uh ding is choosing or trying to
remember what move order he's he's
looked at whether it's Knight bd7 or A5
very often there are
um really similar and that is also why
he's probably thinking perhaps he has
both options available to him
um but um yeah as I mentioned this play
is not forced so it is only logical that
the players already started taking their
time because even if you know that your
next move is A5 anyway likely you might
be out of book three moves later and you
might as well start thinking now
and there we go Knight bd7 instead I was
about to say I'm slightly concerned that
Ding is thinking considering it was him
who chose this line him who kind of uh
picked the whole variation but
yeah very normal move uh I guess that
Knight is flexible right now
um is it going to park itself on f8 here
Niche uh or is it going to stay on D7
just in case black does start pushing
those Queen side Pawns oh as I mentioned
because of this
uh yeah I assume Jan is castling short I
think long Castle in this particular
position is not what people uh people
usually do so I think uh Castle short is
going to happen and then um Knight f8 to
G6 is no longer possible because of the
Paul on H6 so I think what black usually
does in these uh positions is go for
Knight H5 that's also what ding did
against me I think against me ding
played the move A5 first
um and then he played Knight H5 to move
later the differences are very subtle
usually it's a transposition of Swords
uh so you you get this Knight a try
Bishop should be some Queen sound
position and I think we will get that
one um today as well and I had a game
with ding he played the very uh that
game he played very quickly was a rapid
game he played very quickly and very
convincingly and I got nothing I was not
expecting the system I didn't prepare
anything specific and uh that game ended
in a draw and I remember feeling that
you know I let things off the hook there
I prepared some sharp Nim so I had some
idea in mind but he just went for uh for
this and escaped very easily now Jan I
believe uh will pose more problems
because of course in this position why
it has on different different ideas
you can still go for the minority attack
or you can try to go for fce4 setup uh
still lots of play left here um but
let's see let's see the what happens if
Knight H5 indeed will follow or
everything once again goes for this A5
move which is flexible
Anish what do you make of 94 in this
position because I faced that kind of
move a lot in in online Blitz does that
work tactically
is that an alternative
I guess that you had a lot of games here
against nihal sarin because I had a lot
of games in this new house are in uh yes
in this in these but for some reason
he's playing them extremely well I've
been getting attacked a lot by him so
what happens very often actually in this
Carlsbad although black seems to have a
passive position
they shift the focus to the uh King side
and black often manages actually to set
up an attack on the king side more often
than not there was a once a beautiful
game between Peter liko and Vladimir
kramnik in the the Legends as Legends of
Chess here I have I have a Mark here
Legends of Chess uh Champion store
tournament and um so it could happen the
white goes for the before B5 plan and
black stars uh counter Planet King set
94. so what I would like to say about 94
is the Thematic move what happens very
often is then okay we take on E7 Queen
E7
and now Bishop E4 D4 now if our Knight
has been on
um F3 we would have to lose time with
Knight D2
um and that
and here we don't have to waste that
move the Knight already is well placed
on E2 it can go to F4 or G3 so I believe
in this particular version when the
Knight is only two Knight E4 is
considered to be inaccurate and you see
the bar is slightly in White's favor
that said of course uh if we're gonna
play a Blitz game now me against you I'm
sure I'll get mated a couple of times
with white because you'll go Knight F5
Knight F6 H5 H4 and whatnot but uh
objectively if white plays uh accurately
here one of the ideas is at some point
to go like Knight to 84 and then going
to C5 once the Knight comes to F6 so you
try to trade queens or sometimes you go
for G5 actually D5 is a very common idea
also trying to immediately create
counter play in the center the queen
side distracting black from the
potential uh plans on the king side so
if White's accurate usually in this
particular version why it should get an
advantage objectively
so I think 94 with the Knight on E2 in
this particular position is not how a
black treats usually it's it's without
an F3 so I yeah I think the choice is
mainly between Knight H5 and A5 first he
played A5 luck against me I didn't
really understand why he did it against
me but he did it again now so he insists
on this I'm quite pleased that he used
you know what he what he thought was
worthy of playing against me in Rapid he
finds worthy of playing uh in the world
championship match game I feel I feel
honored you know that that he wasted
much prep against me in that rapid game
A5 is indeed on the board and you know
what else is on the board dingley Ren is
not on the board uh at least not yet but
he is at the board and I want to bring
your guys attention to the fact that I
might be jumping the gun here this might
be unimportant but thus far I think
janapamnishi has gotten up quite a bit
more than dingley Ren
um as ding he continues to sit at the
board you know 15 20 seconds after the
move has been played David that has been
very very unusual ding has made a b line
literally every move right for the rest
area do you make anything in the early
going of ding's habits at the board is
this a conscious choice to uh to sit
more at the board or
do you think this is unimportant
yeah I'm going to reserve uh judgment on
that just for a few more moves but I
like the fact that he's been sitting at
the board
um you mentioned it Dania there's been a
lot of uh posts on social media about it
maybe he's aware of that maybe his
second Richard Rapport has had a word
with him saying okay you need that extra
time you need to be able to focus get in
the zone uh maybe he's just been scarred
by that previous defeat and that was one
of the main takeaways from it but uh
either way it's nice to see him there
sitting at the board Jan maybe putting
the pressure on saying okay you have to
sit there because I'm gonna move uh
super fast and he plays A3 very quickly
and ding back on the move
I think actually long term in this match
it's going to help him uh doing if he
kind of gets in this rhythm of uh only
going away when he really needs to we
saw what happened last year of course
what were your conclusions uh Anish
Daniel about uh both of the players
habits playing habits and body language
in the first two games
yeah it's a generally a fascinating uh
question you know how much to get up
from the board now you are not supposed
to in the normal tournament setting get
up from the board when it's your move
this rest air resting area is a luxury
that players have only in top
tournaments and uh having a resting area
with a screen where you can see your
board is very rare even in top
tournaments and so you normally cannot
afford this and you're supposed to sit
behind the board but whether you get up
from the board during your opponent's
move or not that's the choice and many
players have different habits Peter
swedler is known to walk very fast
facing around the entire playing hole I
also like to walk around quite a bit but
you have players in particular wrestling
topalov who makes this a case in just
sitting at the board the entire time and
I believe that it's a decision here and
his uh manager made they decided at some
points to follow Bobby Fischer's path to
the top and Bobby Fischer was always
sitting at the board as well and uh this
approach is very very interesting
especially if combined with Incredible
um incredible stamina which is what
Vaseline always had I I know he is
extremely fit he's been swimming uh
kilometers as for for his preparation
and with that approach you've got this
stamina and you see the for five six
hours straight behind the board you can
think the entire time not burn yourself
out because you're super fit and gain
that extra time
while for normal people who are less fit
than Vaseline if they are to do that
they will at some point simply plunder
stuff and even Vaseline who is very fit
this is one of the reasons why he's
sometimes blundered because the
concentration is just too high for too
long of a period of time and at some
point the brain is collapsing and
plundering something but I also want to
mention is that Jan played A3 very
quickly I think he is aware of my game
against uh ding because A5 didn't come
as a surprise now he recollected his
preparation I remember that A5 is met by
A3 and now it's uh to up to dink to a
show if he has a different move than
Knight H5 which is what people usually
do here
no I just was going to mention that
we've emphasized the F3 E4 idea but of
course there's also the stock minority
attack on the queen side B4 B5 uh that
is being actively prepared with A3
yeah uh definitely and also maybe just a
bit of a waiting game he's asking uh a
black witch plan he's going to go for um
Anish mentioned that F3 is often met by
a B5 B4 so
um he's kind of saying okay you can
commit to B5 but now I want to weakened
my Center as white and uh you might
regret that plan the black C6 Pawn will
simply be a Target yeah interesting from
Jan I like it uh this last move for
white very flexible but uh yeah I'm not
sure which one he's going to go for I
think he'll wait to see
um yeah how ding reacts first of all I
was going to say Anish it's really
fascinating to kind of kind of stamina
sitting at the board uh question I know
that uh the English kind of number one
long term number one Michael Adams said
he made a conscious decision when he was
in his mid-20s to stop walking around
and that's how he has this longevity
he's in his 50s now still
still a phenomenal player he just never
gets up and I can't do that I get
Restless I need to kind of I have this
curiosity to look at other games
um but these players they don't have
that it's just purely their own game
whether they're in their rest room
whether they're kind of uh sitting at
the board they're still thinking about
the moves so yeah it's just interesting
whether they see better on a kind of
computer screen or on the physical
pieces themselves
what do you think
yeah I I think the question is
interesting but I think ding has
answered that question for himself uh
the previous game where he spent a lot
of time thinking uh in front of the
screen he as he confessed he missed a
lot of things he missed for example GTX
F6 after thinking for
um half an hour almost behind the screen
and so he concluded that this whole
behind the screen thinking is maybe not
for him not right now and I like it I
think ding um you know
he's scarier when he is at the board
he's sitting there you see him
concentrating like for some now I look
at the ding
Aesthetics right look at thing I look at
his hands I look at his head I feel you
know the I feel the energy the thought
the thought thinking process and Asian
aware of things sitting there I mean
this this is a thinker this is a chess
player this is the one that you fear uh
the one that has been in Carlson uh the
one that has won many tournaments the
one that has been 2800 that is being
clear in their sitting thinking and that
is how I I like to see him and how is
the most feared not in a restroom a
resting area with the with the hoodie on
uh you know looking uh looking cold and
and miserable this is this is the thing
that we know
mm-hmm
what's your lifetime score like against
Ding and he's just out of curiosity you
mentioned you've had pretty much this
exact position against him
I was quite fortunate uh in many of my
games against Ding and I think my score
against him is actually pretty good
but the couple of losses that I had
against him were extremely impressive so
I think I was able to play pretty good
chess against him even in the games that
I lost but there are some games where he
played from start to finish in absolute
Masterpiece so there was a game in
sinful coupler he won the tournament
where he beat Carlson in the tie break
at that time I made one strategic
inaccuracy or a mistake in the opening
that was not at all obvious to me but he
had outplayed the masterfully
demonstrating why that that one move was
a mistake and uh of course I made more
mistakes but none of them were obvious
and it was an absolute Masterpiece I
really learned a lot from that game and
many people are praised his his play
there I think it was brilliant also I've
had uh a couple of Rapid losses against
him um where he played the Catalan in a
very masterful fashion nurturing a small
Edge without making a single mistake and
I only had to air once or twice and
there was there was one instance also
where we played at an Olympiad and um I
only was managed to manage to escape
because his team has already beaten my
mind so by making a draw he essentially
um won the match so if not if the score
in the match would have been equal he
would have probably managed to beat me
in that game as well but I I was lucky
against him in multiple other games so I
have a decent score
but I I do have tremendous respect for
him and I think when ding brings his a
game to the table is uh one of the best
players in the world and in certain
positions uh especially with the white
pieces I think he is a very good uh
player with the white pieces he has
outplayed Magnus Carlson even in some
rapid games these are the positions that
he understands he performs at an
incredibly high level as he himself
mentioned in interview he's you know
he's a big
um big fan of uh computers and she has
AI interests and he he wants to play
like Ai and I think in some in some
cases he achieves that that kind of
level when the positions that he
understands and I I do hope for him that
today's position he also understands
he's playing with the black pieces but I
guess he is into finesses
I I didn't see what alternative
um what sensible alternative he had at
this point Knight H5 is the standard
move
is indeed Knight H5 is on the board
after a significant think and we will
see by force a trade of dark squared
Bishops so the position kind of quieting
down here very strategic I'm sure that
there are still games in the database
and I was just going to add as a
commentator I've tried to pay a lot less
attention I said this on the Last
Broadcast to the body language of the
players because I've learned that the
body language is incredibly
unpredictable the same facial expression
the same reaction with three different
players means three different things but
I think just objectively the dingley ren
that we see here right now is a more
confident dingler and I don't think that
you can argue with that David it just
you just get a bit of a different feel
obviously we're still very early in the
game we're still in the opening phase
but I think a pretty auspicious sign
that Ding isn't running toward the break
room you know he's moving methodically
and he's fully focused on the board
yeah we talk about surprises in the
opening surprises on the board but it's
also nice to surprise your opponent uh
with body language I guess and it's just
a statement to Yan uh if nothing else
just that he's serious now that he's
focused that he's in the zone and um
yeah of course uh quick reply there both
moves forced as you mentioned that
Daniel but I'm expecting ding to sit at
the board and he does continue to do so
I think if he was going to go with his
strategy of kind of darting off uh going
walking around chilling then this would
have been a good moment to get up uh Jan
has a bunch of interesting moves a bunch
of plans to choose from and uh I'm
expecting him to spend a bit of time so
yeah I think this was the moment that we
can confirm ding has learned from the
experiences of date of day one of the
first two games and he's going to be
sitting there
um time trouble did play an issue uh did
play a part right in uh game two in his
defeat there almost was decisive in game
one two so if you can save an extra
couple of minutes on the clock by
sitting at the board that makes a lot of
sense
um now white to play Yan do we think
he's going to go for this minority
attack that we've been uh alluding to a
bit uh it feels harder now at least to
push any Pawns in the center
well yeah I I'm a little surprised how
long uh Jan is taking because I I was
fooled into thinking that he is in his
in his preparation when he played A3
this quickly because A3 is not a must
and this particular position yeah I
think he's trying to memorize uh you
know what what was his setup it's a very
subtle position I remember when when I
looked at this kind of position with
engine it gives all sorts of different
moves with around the same evaluation
and what the engine really likes to do
is it sometimes plays a move like Rook a
to B1 and then if black reacts to it in
a certain way it goes then The Rook from
B1 to E1 or It also says you can also go
first to E1 if black reacts in a certain
way you can then go back to B1 and so
like these positions they're extremely
subtle because the idea of B4 is also
somewhat committed after before a b a B5
is sometimes an idea where the Knight
heads or B6 to C4
also before uh beef yeah
yeah I mean the 9694 is an idea
um when it's a big question who
benefited from weakening the C4 and C5
squares another thing is that even if
white gets B5 even if white gets BC bcbc
there are some classical games where
white was able to exploit this one
weakness because then later in some rook
and game they played G4 exclamation mark
and
also
um created the weakness on H6 but in re
in the rook and game of course yeah not
not in the middle game but in reality in
the modern day in reality this minority
attack ideas
they're not going to win you many games
especially classical games black only
has one weakness and if everything gets
traded black will play H5 now this is
well known you don't allow G4 in The
Rook end game and with only one weakness
on C6 it is not the end of the world for
black so
minority attack is uh is a viable plan
but it's not already crushing at the
same time the plan of F3 E4 is also very
hard to execute there is this idea of
going uh Rook A1 and then the Knight
away somewhere and F3 but then after F3
uh as I mentioned black can play uh
black can play C5 black can also play
Queen G5 now when after Queen G5 both
the rook and the queen are targeting the
E3 pawn and it's very hard so uh push E4
Sometimes some players have played moves
like Knight D1 but once you go Knight D1
and then F3
I mean with the Knights so passive on D1
are you really are you really happy to
open the center this way I'm not sure so
the position is extremely solid for
black extremely robust and uh
Jan seems to yeah not not the uh not
remember exactly what he prepared and I
have to say I don't know how relevant
this is because Jan is a very gifted
player very talented one but
I don't think he has any experience in
the carlsbads with neither color I think
he lost that game against Carlson with
the black pieces he got out played very
very badly was one of the best games by
Magnus uh it was just two days before
here he withdrew from the singford cup
but the Masterpiece in round one
uh but yeah in in turn unlike Magnus who
Magnus is like a big big uh fan of cards
but he's played so many Karls about
structures from all kinds of openings so
you can also get it uh with both colors
you can get it from London system from
the karokan uh many many systems where
you get the card spot but Jan I think is
not very familiar with the Casual
structures so if he doesn't have his uh
path works out here I am not sure uh the
tip by default will play it very well
and also I think his body language
I noticed he was not thrilled I think he
had some nice plan in the nimsa he was
looking forward to but now he is not
thrilled
yeah and he has just played Rook a to E1
so kind of signaling and Anish you
mentioned the Rook can come to E1 that
doesn't necessarily mean that he is
committing to F3 E4 maybe he's uh doing
a little bit of misdirection but for the
time being we can conclude that he is uh
settling himself in toward preparing the
central plan 92 can drop back to C1 then
F3 and E4 and of course for the time
being black can't really play C5 because
the D5 Pawn is hanging but the knight
from H5 can always return to F6 and the
other drawback of the move C5 when you
combine it with A5 as ding has done then
the B5 Square opens up potentially for
uh White's night so C5 could be a very
very committal move
David black cannot procrastinate because
it seems like he's got a lot of time but
if you think about you know Knight C1 F3
E4 that's only three moves and you don't
just want to put you know put this off
like I've put off my taxes
you're not the only one that done yet
don't worry
um but yeah the type of position oh no
this is the type of position where I
would uh be tanking I would spend 20
minutes trying to figure out how to be
productive as black where to put the
Black Knights what to do how to react to
What uh how white wants to step forward
in the center and
that's uh that's the question I'm hoping
ding already has an answer to again he
chose the variation
um he chose this setup he's got
experience here against the niche uh no
less than a niche so um I'm sure he's uh
he's got a setup in mind Daniel you
mentioned uh kind of not procrastinating
what does that involve maybe uh
improving the Black Knights I'm not sure
which direction uh this one at some
point needs to decide whether it wants
to step back
um you've kind of got three moves that
plan we mentioned for White Moving Out
The Way F3 E4 um so black does have a
bit of time yeah because uh it feels
like there must be decent ideas at his
disposal Anish I think you can probably
provide you have more experience in this
position but it seems to me that there's
a cat and mouse situation with the
Knight on H5 if it drops back to F6 too
early then um black might allow
whitesnite to acts as sort of prime real
estate on G3 which is it seems to me a
perfect square from which it can prepare
F3 and E4 so maybe it's in Black's best
interest to remain on H5 until white has
played Knight C1 and then jump back to
F6 and David yeah I second your point
about the other night B6 does seem like
the most natural Square Knight D7 to F6
looks really really awkward than the H5
Knight runs out of square so Anish would
you second this kind of setup Knight B6
and then delaying Knight F6 until
White's committed uh the Knight to C1
I think you brought a very good point I
think Knight H5 to F6 is not to move
your uh play quickly it's not a move you
need very often either because even
after F3 E4 if the Knight moves away
from E2 your knight from H5 gets access
to F4 so I don't think you want to
retract the knight from H5 too quickly
um
I wanted to just add also one point to
what you said when you said Knight D2 F6
looks bad now it does it looks odd but
it's not as awkward as it seems because
very often I have an idf6 you then go G6
followed by Knight G7
supporting Bishop F5 and then suddenly
the knights do make sense so Knight df6
is not out of the question in these kind
of structures but indeed black usually
chooses between Knight B6 Knight F6 and
Knight f8 and also Queen G5 first I
think Queen G5 is a very common idea in
these kind of positions and uh
ding uh is taking his time I mean I'm
pretty sure I think okay one I think
that must have been my game against him
as well I think that's literally we're
still following my game against him uh
we have to check that but I'm pretty
sure
yeah I'm pretty sure indeed this is my
game
uh but
I guess ding is trying to to think maybe
Jan has an improvement somewhere also
I'm sure he doesn't recall all the
details either there are also many
different options of around same value
so he's trying to get into the game
trying to go deep into his thoughts and
I'm curious if Jan actually has
something real prepared or if he just
saw a couple of games uh has has his
very superficial knowledge of this
position and just follows my game
sometimes also you might mix up
sometimes you have seen a game and you
have prepared something and you mix
these two up together so you think that
you prepared the e3k1 but actually it's
just my game
it's not his prep he just remembers the
the 3K one and then later on the second
one but yeah that was the end game of
financial I just played like an idiot
you should have played completely
different you know so maybe that's
that's happening I don't know
foreign
openings uh pretty much I just look at
other people's games and try and copy I
never know whether it's good bad but uh
I'm very influenced by the result in the
database as well uh there was a famous
uh very famous case uh actually in the
match between Vichy and Magnus the
second match where visha was uh maybe
she came a little closer and he managed
to beat Magnuson get into game three and
what happened is that Magnus followed
he followed the game of Michael Adams
his second all the way until he got a
lost position
and that is because I believe Magnus had
not confused him very often you see that
people they remember
they study games and what you should do
or what you should do and what you
should not do and they remember
what they should not do but they don't
remember that they should not do that
that happens a lot and the biggest
example was world championship match so
it can happen yeah but of course yeah
okay one it cannot be so bad but whether
that's Jan's prep or not we will see and
ding is taking it his time he can afford
to he has plenty of time now the
position is not too forced but I do
expect him to make a move at some point
soon because and he does now yeah
and it is it is Knight D7 to fa deciding
on the placement of his Knight opening
up the diagonal for his light squared
Bishop of course this discussion of
being influenced by the previous Grand
Masters who've played a line that
reminds me of I'm channeling my inner
Yasser here that famous story involving
a Young Vicious uh yes and and Robert
Huebner and that adjusted his glasses
and said in his accent
um or was it in Austria I don't remember
where the tournament was but anyways
visionande decided to play a Petrov in a
game against Colombian GM Alonso Zapata
um and now I'm saying all this in
yasser's voice this was the 80s now in
order to prepare he had looked at the
chess informant which was what you used
back in the day in order to prepare
openings and he had seen a game of GM
Larry Christensen in uh an interesting
and rare Petrov line that game had ended
in a draw he thought that's an
interesting line I haven't seen it
before so he decides to repeat it
against Alonso Zapata it turns out that
that is a blunder it blunders a piece on
move four this is viciano's shortest
loss of his career and it turns out the
game Larry Christensen had drawn in that
line was a pre-arranged draw so the
players had just randomly selected a
move not realizing that it was actually
a blunder and that is how vishi lost
that game so you always have to take
other people's games and moves with a
bit of a grain of salt we could perhaps
show that line David yeah you're doing
that right now of course Knight F6 uh 95
D6 this is the mainline Petrov Knight
f394 standard Fair Knight C3 and in this
position Christensen had debuted Bishop
F5 hey she said it's a pretty
interesting move why does it lose
because after Queen E2 you resigned the
game Queen E7 is forced and now Knight
D5 sends the queen back where it came
from and then D3 picks up the Black
Knight so always check lines
independently of who played them
you know he's achieved so many uh so so
much in his career as a five-time world
champion Legend one of the best players
of all time greatest players of all time
and uh he has to be constantly reminded
by all sorts of commentators of that one
game he once plundered and I see this
game being remembered on all sorts of
occasions much too often and like now
also what where did this game come from
which he will be watching our broadcast
later he'll be seeing you'll be like why
guys why what have I done just as a
Carlsbad on the board why why am I game
against the faster can we please get
over it it's been 40 years it's time to
time to be 40 years
wow
I'll uh I'll save fishy's blushes as
well by offering up my own painful
example where it's definitely better to
know nothing than nothing at all than
something and that was against you Anish
when I uh in my game I think it was 2009
or 10 in Vikings day in the B group and
I followed some line and it was exactly
what was in my notes what not to do for
black and I remember we blitzed to like
move 20 and then I sat there realizing I
was completely lost and wanted to resign
so yeah it's definitely sometimes better
it happened to all of us uh I think it
is just how memory works I guess the
memory you you remember lines but you
don't remember what's attached to them
you don't remember the evaluation of
course you if you refreshed it recently
you do but if you looked at it too long
ago or you didn't look at it with full
concentration then you might mix mix up
I've heard the same I've heard it from
Luca and Valley also when he played his
bike and Zay tournaments and he was
losing in all the neither 55 Knight of
the sharp neither of Sicilians the his
coach was constantly complaining he said
that you know I realized I should never
show Luke what not to do because every
time I show him what not to do he does
exactly that
yeah that's why I started playing old
man chess where you can't lose straight
out of the opening even if you forget
everything but meanwhile Knight C1 on
the board as expected
yeah you know preparing after
I have once uh played this Knight C1 uh
I don't know Knight C1 F3 couldn't have
two plan
um and then people started repeating it
because I won a nice game against
frisnet
but I I'm really not sure this is such a
great great plan
and um
I I think the
modern computers are not big fans of it
anymore
and I wonder how How Deeply young has
looked at this but uh whether whether he
had actually looked at it in great
detail or whether it was something very
superficial where he just knew this plan
and and the sort of yeah and uh
he's just following it because I believe
that black has multiple ways even in
this even in my game against ding ding
what he played was he just met F3 with
C5
and uh we got a position where he has an
isolated Pawn but I had this weakness on
E3 and I didn't get anywhere maybe like
my play can be improved but in that
rapid game I got absolutely nowhere so
we'll see we'll see what ding will do
but in general I like the game for ding
by the way so far I like that he's
sitting behind the board I like the
position I like that Jan is not so
familiar with it
um I like that it's solid and uh there
is room for um creativity the room for
minor inaccuracy for black you don't
have to be super precise I think
um so far I personally feel it's a good
outcome from the opening and I am
optimistic for Ding and his fans I like
just that he sits there at the board and
I like his composure and I think we
might see him back in the match at some
point maybe if not today then uh in the
upcoming days
it would be a success for him right just
to get on the scoreboard just to get out
of this black game with some good
emotions just uh knowing he didn't face
too many troubles
um but what moves are we expecting you
mentioned that he wants to be ready to
meet uh F3 by breaking with C5 so I'm
expecting something that defends the D5
Pawn
maybe developing this bishop
um
does he want to continue maneuvering his
Knights now that uh this night has gone
away from G3 from F4 maybe black can
drop back with this piece now Knight F6
is an option now certainly not that the
Knight is left you two Knight F6
certainly becomes an option especially
now that F3 can be met with C5 uh but
again he can also go for this
Queen G5 idea I believe I think that
that's what people do this queen G5 move
uh yeah
definitely in a Blitz game Queen G5 it's
a page three I would start you know
salivating at the prospect of some
tactics except you know I'd play Someone
Like Anisha would just send my queen
away obviously we should point out that
F4 I think is attempting move for
players less initiated and typical plans
but now how are you gonna play E4 the
queen more than happy to return even
back to d8 so with white ons can't go
backwards that is the operating
principle in this position
yes Daniel wrench has told us the pawns
can move backwards but I have to say the
one little detail I noticed that after
Queen G5 actually Bishop H3 might not be
a threat at all because if let's say I
make a waiting move like let's play
Knight B3
after Bishop H3 I suspect you might be
losing a piece to F4
G4 and King H1
so Bishop H3 is maybe not uh directly a
threat
but you don't have to follow it up with
distribution you can just type in G5
with the idea to prevent F3 for now
maybe sometimes there's a smooth G6 uh
you know to to go for Bishop 97 Bishop
of five plan sometimes uh I'm
or or you can you can move the Knight
back now to F6 perhaps with the queen on
G5
and you got sort of the queen outside
the um
yeah you got the coming out let's say
it's now active and next maybe you want
to go H5 uh H5 H4 kind of things it's
it's very subtle these positions very
hard to say but maybe you could try to
hint at some uh attacking potential on
the king side
so lots of options certainly I think
this moment is a very critical moment
after Knight C1 I think ding must be
aware of of this but maybe he thought it
was also critical and so he is wondering
now what Yan has prepared he is trying
to think if there is a trap awaiting him
um at the end somewhere and trying
trying to choose between the different
options
indeed a very rich position diverse in
plans for both sides white seems to be
banking on the classical idea F3 E4 ding
is searching for the best setup to take
the sting out of that plan we are just
about an hour 50 minutes in to this
third game folks of the 2023 v-day world
championship and uh the brunt of the
action is still ahead but before we take
our first break of the day we wanted to
remind you that if you dreamed of
playing in the fide World Championship
well chess.com is making your dreams
come true sort of you can now challenge
both World Championship contenders in
bot form dingley Ren and Jana Pony Bots
are available for play right now at
chess.com play slash computer so head
over there and let us know if you can
beat the Bots use x-glam FWC Bots all
one word in the chat or go to chess.com
play slash computer and match your wits
against all sorts of bots including
well speaking of ding he is at the board
he has been at the board for the vast
majority of this game a welcome sign for
ding fans and a welcome sign uh the kind
of position that he has managed to get
one that might be a little bit less
familiar for yonda palmnushin we will
see both of these players tackle the
challenges as they head into the middle
game and we will head into a break we
will be back with more action from the
fide World Championship in just a couple
of moments
[Music]
thank you Mike Klein here for chess.com
longtime fans of the world championship
know that one of the most divisive
elements of this event is what should
happen in case of a 7-7 tie what is the
best tiebreaker and I think we finally
nailed it it's going to be the Battle of
facial hair now ding's got a little bit
of a mustache going there he's got some
work to do and if we run down let's see
how nipponish he's looking in this stock
photo a little bit better but I see lots
of stubble he's really going to let that
fill in we will see at the end of three
weeks which man has grown it better
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back at the 20 23 feet 8 World
Championship dingley run is playing Jana
pamdushi's Blazer nope he is playing on
the palmishi who is somewhere in the
playing hall probably in the rest area
they are in the midst of a Carl's Bad
structure one of the oldest Queen's
Gambit declined structures it's been
popular for well over a hundred years
and they are just entering uh what
promises to be a very complex and Rich
positional middle game okay the last
move 15 night to C1 as we see
anapomnishi comfortable lounging in the
rest area pulling a dingly wren and ding
of course has been sitting at the board
for most of the game David Knight C1
it's pretty clear that nepo is preparing
F3 E4 and our general consensus seems to
be that Jana isn't particularly
comfortable particularly familiar with
the structure but he is up 15 minutes on
the clock
yeah and the 15 minute Advantage might
come into play a bit later on still
early days in this one things kept up a
good speed if we compare it to uh game
one and game two I think he'll be
feeling much more confident here's black
yes he's spent over half an hour but he
has also Banks almost 15 minutes sir
almost oh sorry almost 15 moves so um he
won't be too concerned in that
department also his position is full of
resources there's a lot of choice right
now Anish was uh really liking this
queen G5 move for black activating maybe
asking some questions about how white is
going to uh set up and uh Anish also in
the break uh you were mentioning that
this still follows your game against
ding himself
yeah I looked it up in fact uh quench 5
is not necessary didn't play Knight F6
back against me is an excellent move and
I I think Jan has um really mixed things
up because I think what he has done um
and what I have done this is not really
promising this Knight C1 idea here
because after Knight F6 I played F3
which is logical and then dig played 96
first
I played Queen to F2 which was also
logical
and here dink played C5 which eventually
equalized but the engines are just B5
and likes best position a lot here
whether it is some slightly negative
um I I think that this
plan is a common knowledge idea this
Knight C1 because of the because of the
game I won against President maybe some
other games before or after that but
I don't think it's actually that good
and I'm a little surprised that dick is
taking this much time maybe he's
doubting himself because Jan is playing
so quickly but actually young is not
playing so quickly or young standards
having spent 20 minutes in the opening
means he's probably out of book
a small actually in fact a small uh
oversight on Jan's part he has never
played uh he has almost never played the
nimsa he's not familiar with D4
positions and Dink has played this
before this particular sequence entirely
and so Jan should have been you know a
little bit more ready being also a
little bit surprising that he is taking
this much time
I'm slightly puzzled by uh why both
players are taking this long I think Jan
shouldn't have been surprised by Carlos
but ding shouldn't be surprised by the
game that he already had before I mean
against me he played the best move
Knight F6 if he will now not play the
best move that would just be very very
strange
and do you think uh it's just again it's
the Mind Games it's the notes that are
forcing him to think forcing him to kind
of second-guess and doubt himself
because otherwise he must have analyzed
that game with you at least even briefly
and uh if there were no problems then
why not repeat
so I think like something's going on
what has happened
um is that Ding has concluded a long
time ago that this what white has done
what I have done is not principled so he
has sort of uh studied much more
principled setups by why it's much more
principled ideas
and he just never came back to this
anymore and so he simply forgot what his
solution was
and that is perhaps why he's taking so
much time it's because sometimes when
somebody does something very harmless
then you just
um don't look at it anymore and then you
forget it and you what you remember much
more is the more critical continuations
perhaps I remember some critical lines
in this but this he just saw okay this
was bad now he's trying to remember why
was this not so principle what was what
did I do was it my game against uh Anish
or not anyway that's these games that we
played I mean I remember them but for
him it was deep night you know there's
the jet lag there's this time difference
and this Champion story events were
always very late he was playing at 4am
in the morning I think he was barely
awake maybe you know making a drug has
been half awake state doesn't even
remember
um what what was happening there he did
win that tournament but you know that's
because he is very talented maybe he's
just half asleep he doesn't even
remember what what happened in that game
but what happened is Knight F6 F3 Knight
E6 and so uh maybe Jan will not play F3
maybe he'll go for Knight B3 instead but
after Knight f69 B3 Knight E6 I don't
see a
a big idea for white other than F3 that
I saw the computers are just a very
interesting plan to go Knight D2 to F3
to reroute the knight from E2 via B3 D2
to F3 okay possible but um very Superior
artificial and also not uh not too too
scary
um but yeah ding is uh slightly puzzling
he spent already
40 minutes from the start of the game 40
minutes and he seems to be genuinely
thinking look at he's just genuinely
reaching the depth uh the of his uh you
know of his mind trying to think but
this is nothing new he has had it
himself very surprising
yeah and maybe my sorry going down here
no maybe just psyching himself out a
little bit like did he look up my game
against Anish giri do I need to deviate
you know sometimes you get into your
head like that David and you can just
you just endlessly spin spin your wheels
in that regard
yeah exactly
um took the words out of my mouth pretty
much he's definitely overthinking this
one and uh it could be one of those
cases I don't know about you guys but I
play a lot of Blitz games a lot of
rapidgames on chess.com and sometimes
they all just blur into one so it's like
is this this exact position with the
knights and different squares with the
Pawns in different squares so he
probably remembers that game especially
if he won the tournament is that the
chessable Masters 2022. that's not David
David this is the shoes.com broadcast
here we say that each game that you play
hs.com is so important for us we
remember each one of them and they're
very dear so please don't uh don't get
yourself
yeah they're all very dear they helped
me get to where I am today those games
of course but I'm more talking about my
memory and uh as I get older it tends to
fade all the details they do blur into
one all these move orders especially
especially in these kind of closed lock
positions where
each Tempo is maybe uh less valuable and
therefore it's difficult to remember I
have the same with the Italian game for
example so many different movie orders
and
oh my god get me started don't get me
started in the Italian dude oh my gosh
Italian is a big topic of conversations
among the top players everybody
complains you know about the move orders
that is why there's one opening with
lots of more orders this one Carlsbad
structure is also very confusing because
uh the positions where the pawn
structure is the same
and the moves are all similar but can be
made in different move order these are
the confusing ones and here too so the
structure is kind of static and black
can trade the Bishops with Knight H5
with Knight E8 the other Knight can go
to F6 B6 f8 it's all kind of similar but
somewhat different sometimes white has
these positions for example with the
queen on C2 sometimes not with the queen
on C2 and so this mine subtle
differences yeah they can get very
confusing but I suspect that indeed what
we see here is ding
thinking and I understand him and this
is what I the mistake I make a lot in my
chess as well and I try to learn from it
but it's so hard
you constantly think rationally that
your opponent must have prepared because
you had a game this world championship
match the stakes are high it's so often
your opponent just for some reason
hasn't prepared and you overthink it and
I have
yeah and finally he plays Knight F6 and
I've made this mistake a lot
um you overthink it and then finally the
reason is something very stupid the
opponent just says yeah we just forgot
you know there's always a human error in
chess as well in the chest prep as well
you just forget something and
um there's no need to believe that your
opponent has everything worked out you
spend 20 minutes
didn't look at this he forgot for some
reason he just followed some game that
he had seen at some point which was my
game against dink not sure he even
remembers what he follows so ding should
just play confidently play what you
already played and finally he plays
Knight of six
yeah and Black's position is kind of
structurally sound he hasn't played any
kind of strange looking moves so there's
no reason he should be objectively
uh kind of significantly worse anyway so
I agree and sometimes you just gotta
trust your opening I love the mug by the
way Anish I'm just gonna trust your
opening and uh yeah if your opponent's
prepared something deep fine there's
still going to be a way out of it if
you're accurate a bit later on if you
saved enough time to work things out
um so yeah maybe just confidence issue
there uh caused him to think a bit
longer than normal I'm
fully aware of those pitfalls I've done
it so many times myself but uh okay 906
it's a good move and and one that I
think we're all happy to see maybe other
than Jan
how long do we think he'll pause here
before replying very long I think it'll
take an hour and a half actually he'll
have eight minutes after the next move
oh but look it's exactly it's happening
exactly exactly what I told you because
I looked at this with the computer now
F3 is also not not the best move he is
mixing up my game with his prep that's
what's happening he's just following my
game blindly thinking that that's his
prep this is just my game it was not
very good
Anish following your game is always a
good way to do it doesn't matter what
your prep is you can be safe in the
knowledge that you followed in the
footsteps of Anish giri
I feel very flattered yeah but this is
really not not so great no just Knight
E6 uh he'll play Queen F2 is clear to me
already he just he just remembers my
game that's all he remembers but after
Queen F2 the engines suggest this move
B5 but I'm not even sure that uh
might just repeat our game with play C5
I mean I'm not sure dink has analyzed
this because it was so um so uh
non-critical what I did uh I don't even
know B5 what exactly is the point so if
E4
I suspect is before I suspect
not necessarily yeah because I was
wondering um is it is it D E4 fe4 Knight
G4 actually
hmm
E4 is not even a thread
it's Queen G3 Knight takes D4 that's why
what I did makes no sense this this idea
with F3 Queen F2 is just it just makes
no sense
and uh remind us how that game went then
so B5 looks uh strong as you mentioned
but you played uh
because he assumes that E4 is uh is a
threat and he reacted uh with C5 which
was very natural and then okay I don't
remember anymore what I did I think I
might have taken on C5 at some point I
played Bishop to B5
and um
you know I can tell you what happened
what happened is I played very slowly as
and we traded a bunch of pieces and at
some point
I kept like uh two Rooks a knight and
the queen against two Rooks the Knight
and the Queen and I was trying to put
pressure on the D5 Pawn but I had to
constantly uh watch out for my E3 Pawn
and finally I just didn't say anything
to do and
um I was not better at all and
eventually we traded the E3 Pawn for the
D5 pawn and it was a drone rook and game
so even what ding did was kind of good
enough
but uh apparently instead of C5 this B5
because E4 is not even a threat so yeah
it is just uh
is just not uh
yeah it looks very it looks very smart
the plan like doesn't it nice you want
to enough tool like it looks like
something very smart now
yeah a bit too clever right uh sometimes
when players try to be too sophisticated
they don't actually improve their
position they just lose a bunch of time
this might be one of those cases but I I
know what you mean it looks very
harmonious for white but if you can't
play E4 then it doesn't make much sense
it also looks like prep like if you
click through this like you see that one
like C1 F3 Queen F2 you are like oh nice
this guy you know he figured out some
deep concept nice regroup it looks
really nice but it's just uh it was kind
of old old knowledge slash improvisation
of mine which is just not good which was
just not good but for Rapid it's okay uh
but for world championship match yeah
you hope for a little bit better prep of
course than this
it should it seems that there's this
tactical flaw right which Queen on F2 is
targeted by Knight F6 to G4 there are
other ways to prepare E3 E4 so from an
uninitiated standpoint after Knight to
E6 uh as awkward as this move looks
maybe Knight one
to E2 I mean I get that it severs the
connection between the rook and the E3
Pawn uh but black did the same with his
last move but again maybe C5 is even
more effective here now that the E3 Pawn
is unprotected so it looks like the
one-two punch of the possibility of B5
as well as the possibility of C5 is just
what renders White's plan too slow
yeah and I must say I mean I understand
there is logic to go Knight C1 to allow
yourself to go F3 and then you come back
because I played 96. but that being said
still Knight 2c1 and Knight back to E2
that that is not very aesthetically
pleasing
and
um I mean we can of course talk about
this position it's an interesting
position but I think it is pretty clear
that
um this is not Jan's uh Yan's prep and
uh we we should not try to justify you
know the should not try to justify it
and um
uh I am I am mainly curious
curious to see if a dick this thing of
course he doesn't know it he doesn't
remember exactly the evaluation of the
computer he he is pretty sure that Jan
is prepared because you know you assume
the best of your opponent and so he is
kind of worried of course but I guess he
will soon find out that there's nothing
to worry about
and he will he will I hope follow that
uh
the our game and play 96 which is the
best move
yeah I mean what seems to be helping him
is that E4 is a threat in this very
position so he doesn't have all that
many candidate moves so one way or the
other you know by hooker by crook he's
going to stumble into this line and
after the game he's going to regret you
know taking all of this time and
you know you might have heard us because
96 is on the board and we'll see how
quickly nepo responds with Queen F2 or
doesn't respond with Queen if two ding
has finally gotten back gotten over the
board he has played out pretty quickly
yeah yeah you're quick enough to quickly
I think Jan is by by this point uh you
know he is a lost man
um who who believes that my game is the
ultimate ultimate truth and his
preparation so I won't be surprised to
see young playing queen of two very
quickly and very confidently but uh yeah
this is not not a good move I have to
say that uh ding's damn clock damage is
rather limited uh okay David knows more
about clock management than uh than me
uh he knows all the ins and outs of
spending time but uh one hour 11 minutes
is plenty of time still and even though
he wasted uh he's like 50 or at least 40
minutes
it's it's still the damage is somewhat
limited on things part and if he gets a
good position he has plenty of time to
uh to make sense of it all
yeah and interesting shots of Yanda just
chilling out in his rest area
maybe he realized that he has been
fooled by me when he's looking at the
position and he's like
this makes no sense what this guy did
why am I even following him
he's too far down the rabbit hole now no
turning back wait too late I'm sorry I'm
I'm so sorry
I mean is there a case to be made for
and I keep trying to infuse this
position with new life I get the black
is is doing fine but if B5 is a serious
problem I mean would we consider a move
like E4 I feel like the positional gods
are laughing at me but does white have
to make a move which prepares E4 or is
there some move that basically Treads
water and takes this thing out of B5
I mean
A4 is so desperate
[Music]
um
I I don't know I think the it's the case
yeah there's a good saying for this it's
it's a case of
the medicine what is the English way of
saying it medicine is worse than the
Cure
sorry medicine is worse than the disease
yeah maybe the cures wasn't the disease
or something yeah exactly but that that
is the case of A4 I think B5 is not such
a big threat that
um it's worth stopping it with A4
it is a very ugly movie for of course
although it's not as bad as it looks
perhaps because you you do also fixate
that B5 Square in case of C5 so after
black we'll play C5 upon A4 will look a
lot better but uh from the moves we've
seen so far I I think Knight one to E2
surprisingly looks uh the most sensible
to me
um
maybe because Knight B3 doesn't really
create a threat of E4 because there is
A4 after that
and okay after Knight one E2 I think the
big question is um
the big question is if E4 is actually a
threat there are many ways to prevent
this E4 move yeah I mean I besides this
B5 and C5 I could also move my queen to
like d8 it also stops E4
many options
I was going to ask do we think Jan is
going to feed into this narrative that
he's still in preparation just to try
and scaling keep the Mind Games going
but he's certainly kind of uh revealed
the truth now by pausing not coming back
to the board immediately not uh kind of
instantly playing a move such as Queen
F2
and uh yeah I mean all of these ideas
you're mentioning they make some sense
but uh Jan's got to weigh all of these
up I mean A4 has long-term consequences
uh Knight back to E2 feels like an
admission of defeat somehow and uh if
Queen F2 isn't convincing either then
it's not going to be feeling too happy
inside
um it's first to think in at least a
while now that all said uh okay so let's
say
um his plan is not working out the E4
push is not happening and that all said
even without doing anything and you just
sit on this position white isn't worse
uh either so why there's a solid
position but of course so your first
goal coming out of the opening is to get
some play we want to get some initiative
if that failed okay then you look at how
how big is the damage how bad is your
position here the position is fine
position is still equal and so no damage
no big Damage Done y'all can still play
some pointless moves like King H1 or any
any move uh back and forth yeah
I don't know about that Anish and I was
gonna actually show a tactic with that
same idea but it was the only with the
blunders congratulations one more let me
one happy there's one where there's
Bishop F5 which I thought was
interesting I think Bishop F5 instead
also falls for Knight takes D4 and after
Ed for Queen E1 at the end of the line
it looks like white emerges with a queen
and a piece for the two Rooks but no
King F2 Bishop takes F5 and the queen is
overextended yes and Rook takes C1 black
of course has an overwhelming amount of
material for the queen so there are
latent tactics in this position anytime
there's two Rooks in a standoff there
always are going to be tactics
that's why I don't like to play bullet
against Daniel because this is how our
games usually end up at H1 hit go Knight
D4 instantly and I'd be like why did I
find the only move in this position in
the blunt or something
[Laughter]
oh sneaky stuff
just to put that on the board and back
rank Checkmate incoming wow
I'm looking at this stuff
and I want to mention that so when you
believe that you are following your prep
and you are actually not there comes a
moment sooner or later and it rather be
sooner than later when you realize that
every like the dots connect in your mind
and you realize oh wait a second
I've got it all wrong and I think we've
reached that point now uh judging from
the body language and Young's thinking I
think he remembers Queen F2 but he so
slowly sees that the move queen of 2
makes no sense
and then he's he slowly Dawns on him
that way that was not the prep
wait and then and now you see he's not
too thrilled and he's taking his time
and okay he has to basically switch to
to plan B and just play some chess and
not not King H1 nor Bishop F5
but uh some neutral move so maybe Knight
B3 Knight one E2
I don't know what other moves are are
there Queen to D2 maybe um
but it's not fun because you know what
especially when you already committed to
F3
you really want to prepare E4 that's
really the point of F3 otherwise it's
just a weakening move yeah it's it's a
move that has a plan so you really you
really want to push to prepare you for
and you don't want to just uh play F3
and then start playing aimlessly
yeah so it's the hardest when you
finally have to engage your brain you
can't rely on Preparation or pattern
recognition anymore and uh yeah already
in the tank for over five minutes now
Jan um I'm expecting it to be longer and
if I would think I would come back sit
at the board just to sit and uh stare
him down gaining in confidence uh just
by the fact he's thinking
and for ding it's the it's the greatest
moment is the opposite so Jan was
playing fast so ding is like bracing for
impact he realized that he is following
his own game and he's like okay now
we'll come a note now we're coming out
and
unless you brace for impact and you see
that nothing comes
and that is a huge moment of relief and
then you realize oh wait a second he
just my opponent just had nothing in
mind actually my opponent had something
mixed up and I'm actually fine and this
was a false false flag so
um you look hands in the pockets ding
with a swag there the jacket is on the
sofa he's walking around all cool
me too
on the board
yeah the move that makes more sense to
me I must say at this point
yeah and uh notice how ding came in
looked at the screen realized a move had
just been played and I think he's
walking back to the board there we go
takes the seat again so different from
game two I guess where we saw him
sitting there just kind of staring at
the screen
realizing he prefers the physical pieces
and yeah we weren't too impressed by
this move either it feels like White's
kind of yo-yoing back and forth
bit of indecision but uh the key
question is
E4 a threat or not right now
yeah I believe uh there are two options
in this kind of positions so and I think
it depends a lot on whether ding has
looked at our game uh in great detail
after or he just concluded that the game
was fine sometimes you know you play a
game it was not too forcing and you just
uh you sort of think okay you concluded
something from the game and you don't
analyze it again
so there are two plans there's the plan
of C5
and the plan of B5 and if ding hasn't
looked at our game in detail he will
just play C5 because he would conclude
from the game that C5 is fine and it is
fine
but if ding had looked at our game he
would know that B5 is even stronger and
here as well B5 is a move preferred by
the computer which is actually much more
double-edged
so I think this is a big big moment so
C5 the more human move and B5 is a move
of someone who is better prepared and
already looked at it with the computer
of course you can also make a neutral
move like I mentioned Queen David I
didn't like 28 I mean it prevents E4 but
I don't think it improves Black's
position by any means so I I think
either C5 or B5 is what I expect let's
see
yeah E4 just seems very unimpressive to
me because the D4 upon such a big
weakness I'm trying to tease out the
complications David maybe can help me
out B5 E4 if we could put that on the
board
um not sure in what order black should
do things but let's say d e f e
first I mean black has a lot of question
the answer should Black Throne B4 which
is not necessarily given because Knight
G4 is a very typical move yeah um in
these Carlsbad positions because this
comes really fast if white plays Knight
G3 already there are tactics now Knight
64 is hanging Knight takes H2
everything falls apart if you make one
step in the wrong direction but other
than Knight G4 black could also play on
The Queen side with B5 B4 so I think you
guys have better intuition in this
structure I don't really play this with
either caller so David I'll start with
you how do you think black should
approach this position maybe Queen A7
yeah so many forcing moves here I would
just start by looking kind of going back
to basics looking for those uh threats
uh all those moves that actually Force
white to react Queen A7 like you say
Daniel looks very tempting I guess there
you have to figure out uh can white even
defend the D4 Pawn if not we might just
uh be able to go for this with
confidence
um Queen A7 yeah I would be looking
whether white has any sacrifices I don't
think they quite work on F6 just to open
up the black king Knight G4 as well
massive threats on the board in multiple
directions
um I'd be calculating that one very
eagerly I think maybe if I were Yan as
white uh after a move like B5 of course
I want to play for but I would be
panicking after uh seeing that black has
so many options that create so many
threats and of course this calculation
time that's how the players do things at
this level but uh yeah just a kind of
superficial glance and all of these look
very tempting the E4 Queen A7 Knight G4
all of them create threats at what point
do you even kind of uh stop calculating
as white
I think it would be for the next couple
of moves and I'd say okay too soon I've
got to look for options so here maybe uh
Yan would be looking kind of in
different direction maybe Knight G3 we
mentioned just trying to get around to
the F5 Square
um if in doubt why not save a bit of
time on the clock and go for something
less forcing that keeps the game
um keeps the game tense
um yeah how about you Anish yeah I agree
with uh with what you just said I think
E4 as Dania mentioned I mean it's a nice
exercise to think of what is the
roughest punishment to E4 maybe it is
like it's a nice little challenge but
it's not something Jan is looking into
so before he sees he I think enough to
Sequin A7 to just say okay I'm not doing
that
um I believe indeed uh I like this
Knight G3 followed by Knight C to E2
potentially I think it's a sensible
regroup
I have to be frank the computer really
liked black here suggesting that black
is very very comfortable
but it is not entirely obvious to me
optically and I you you can tell me if
you agree or not but like you still kind
of like the look of this for white uh
because
my Bishop uh is kind of more active and
black spawn structure like optically
looks weaker and the bishop looks kind
of you know light Square Bishop light
squared pawns it's kind of bad vibes
there for black but I guess the computer
comes up with quick before C5 lots of
counter play and the fact that I wicked
my E3 Pawn is a big big downside so I
guess uh position here is comfortable
for black but I guess yeah uh
after B5 E4 is out of question and it's
probably not G3 what else maybe not yeah
I think I think you need to address the
you need to address the Knight of the
three situation and it's not not easy to
say what uh what to do I headed over to
uh to Daniel maybe Daniel has some smart
thoughts for white after B5
no I I understand what you're saying
because if white can engineer the right
set of circumstances E4 can be
incredibly dangerous and we know that
and Knight F5 could call me 45 so the
potential of E4 is not in question but
there's just so many moving parts to
take care of there's the D4 Pawn there's
B5 before there's C6 C5 so it but for
dinghy has to actually choose you can't
just come to a restaurant and look at
all the items you actually have to
choose something off the menu and that
can be incredibly hard like the
abundance of options can potentially be
a bad thing especially as you're dipping
I don't want to say low on the clock but
imperceptibly he's almost spent already
half of his time and as ding continues
to ponder the proper course of action I
think it's a good opportunity for us uh
to remind ourselves of the topsy-turvy
path that Mr ding took to get to where
he is right now in Astana let's take a
listen
dangleren's unpredictable path to this
year's fide World Championship was born
from the right combination of good
fortune and persistent gameplay
ding's journey to Kazakhstan almost
never got started travel restrictions in
China prevented him from qualifying for
the candidates the Gateway tournament to
the world championship but when a spot
unexpectedly opened up ding ground away
to earn the vacated seat and punch his
ticket to Madrid
[Music]
his foot in the candidate's door ding
struggled in the first half of the
tournament failing to earn a win and
falling to the eventual winner Yana
pomnushi
but that's when the magic began in the
second half ding began to turn things
around starting with a resounding win
over yankea we have a victory for
dingley Wren and his candidates chances
are not gone at this time
ding then continued his momentum with
back-to-back wins over Rickard Rapport
and Fabiano caruana
in his final match of the tournament
ding squared off with Hikaru Nakamura in
a battle for second place with rumors
suggesting Magnus Carlson might step
down as Champion second place at the
candidates now had an entirely new
meaning
needing a win ding took advantage of a
missed Opportunity by Hikaru on move 38
and worked steadily from there to secure
the Victory and second place
second half of the tournament has been
his four wins in seven games
while his runner-up finish at the
candidates was certainly an
accomplishment ding left Madrid without
a seat at the world championship
that all changed later that summer when
Magnus announced he would not be
defending his title
with the five-time champion out of the
mix ding's second place finish at the
candidate suddenly became a golden
ticket to Kazakhstan with the rare
opportunity to cement his name amongst
the distinguished list of fide world
champions much like his opponent ding
chose to skip most of the high-profile
classical events over the past few
months and instead selected to immerse
himself in his preparation to face
neponishi time will tell if that
approach and ding's string of good luck
and competitiveness will earn him the
most famous title In classical chess
so many trials and tribulations that
dingley Wren went through to get to
where he is now it was not guaranteed
until Magnus Carlson shockingly stepped
down abdicated his world champion throne
and wow dangly Ren has yet another
comeback to make he's in full of
comebacks in this past year David I just
what impresses me the most I think is
his resilience the fact that in the
candidates he had incredibly painful
moments that 20 move loss with the black
pieces against team or rajaba were you
as impressed as I was I was on site in
Madrid just kept getting shot down kept
getting back up again and he's rewarded
with a seat at the world championship
table
yeah certainly Dania I'm one of Dick's
uh ding's biggest fans and uh just the
way he yeah just kind of gracefully uh
kind of puts these runs together
remember that 100 game unbeaten streak
as well he's just such a classy player
and I think he needs to take inspiration
from his journey to this point his uh
Journey to the world championship match
it wasn't always uh kind of it didn't
always start well like you say at the
candidates but it ended uh ended in good
fashion and uh he's good at hope that
the match goes the same way of course he
lost to game two but it's still early
days and plenty of time to recover just
like he did in the candidates and it
does feel like it's written in the stars
somehow he was on the outside looking in
and he kind of got gifted this path and
he seized it sees the opportunity with
two hands and
yeah Anish what are your thoughts uh
despite the fact he's one point down now
despite the fact he's half an hour down
on the clock in this game
still chances to make that Fairy Tale
come true
oh very much so and as I mentioned
earlier when I spoke about it with I
spoke about it with Dania in one of the
earlier broadcasts I find it kind of
remarkable the the Cs path
where
on the one hand it seemed that he was
very unlucky and unfortunate as
everything was going wrong with the
covet affecting him most from compared
to all other players even as
restrictions been lifted most countries
China was the last one one of the last
countries when he wasn't able to travel
he wasn't able to get the necessary
number of games to qualify he wasn't
able to play the Grand Prix for example
he was scheduled to to fly to Grand Prix
it didn't work out because of some Visa
issues so everything went against him it
was very unlucky
and then it's turned around but turned
out completely like he started getting
just so
so lucky in in turn and he managed to
qualify to the candidates because he was
just in time to get himself a bunch of
games against Chinese players like some
tournaments started appearing from
nowhere
um
yeah C5 was instantly played just to
finish my point then also of course he
was lucky in the candidates because he
finished second even that was not a
given he was simply at the bottom of the
tournament Table after the first first
half and then
he he managed to finish second just just
in time winning in the last round and
that was enough to qualify it's never
ever been enough to qualify earlier in
Nature's history but this time it was
and uh maybe here too you know it starts
off badly but things will turn around
and he played C5 death
that seems Seems to to me that uh is
he's was also very influenced by the
game that uh we we had played against
him and um he probably didn't study this
B5 kind of ideas in much depth he was
just satisfied with the C5 concept which
uh which is a more natural human concept
trying to equalize the position and have
this D5 weakness compensated by the E3
weakness I guess a very solid position
now for for your ding but B5 would offer
more counter chances more double-edged
game more of three years old game
something I would personally be looking
forward to much more
oh David I want your take on this I'm
going to be honest I don't like C5 at
all and the move that keeps circling
around in my head is Bishop D3 to B5
I've been thinking about it in issues
you've been sharing your insights and I
for some reason can't find like a
satisfactory answer if Bishop D7 I don't
want to go too concrete then takes my
idea was takes Queen takes a knight C3
uh to a foreign suddenly there's Knight
B6 and Knight takes C5 it's a double
attack I call this forking a fork
because you're threatening a fork as
well as the pawn on C5 and I don't know
like that earlier point that we made
about the B5 Square being weak David do
you feel like ding is going a little bit
too much for the bailout here with C5
it does feel that way um if ding was
playing a less uh high pressure match
maybe uh if he was playing a lower rated
opponent such as myself maybe he would
have tried to keep more tension and we
were looking at lines with B5 where as a
niche said it's three results you're
kind of setting some traps potentially
for white but
um yeah I mean I didn't see this uh
tactical shot with beef Bishop B5 I've
got to say but uh even strategically
it's very risky for black now the D5
Pawn is forever weak and this can be
targeted later on the Black Knight and
F6
not necessarily the most stable piece
long term
um even if you kind of trade pawns and
make a symmetrical Pawn structure you do
have holes in your camp
yeah I would be hesitant
um I don't think white should take this
I think a lot of viewers at home might
be wondering oh I can give black an
isolated Pawn but as Anish said earlier
this E3 Pawn is just as weak if not
weaker than uh Black's D5 Pawn so maybe
this is one thing he's hoping for but as
you point out Daniel yeah Bishop B5 one
option I'm wondering how you even react
if white just kind of side steps in
place a move like Queen D2 and weights
uh what is Black's next move
um yeah strategically
maybe not that desirable and it does
come with some risks
um well I wish
I wouldn't personally exaggerate this
danger so Danny I had exactly the same
thought as you in my game I also got
excited about Bishop B5 in the position
that I had there
but uh I remember after Bishop D7 in my
game two there was something that got me
excited so I was thinking okay very nice
but actually he just played rook d8 and
here as well you just play Rook d8
damage is very limited there is no you
can't exploit
my slight uh lag in development at the
same time uh White can also play Queen
D2 indeed now or move earlier but I
think while I don't like C5 because B5
was more funky I don't think that C5 is
bad
um in terms of like trying to equalize I
think that after C5 Jan will event sorry
thing will eventually slowly but surely
equalize I think these positions just in
the long run are okay for black I also
thought they are better for white when I
had my game but
I really struggled in that game to put
pressure
and so I'm really curious to see if Jan
will be able to I don't trust Jan
um as I mentioned he's not known to be a
default player I don't trust him to play
this super precisely
and I think black is just conceptually
all right after Community two I don't
need to rush with C4 because I want to
play C4 only if you can follow up with
B5 before otherwise it's a huge
strategical concession you just released
attention instead I think black has
ideas like Bishop D7 you can defend the
D5 Pawn with Bishop C6 if really
necessary I think you can just play
passively with black and I think
even the worst case scenario things will
be quite uh quite little for white
because only one weakness on D5
especially with the opponent F3
weakening the E3 Pawn I just think that
there is just not too much danger for
black but of course I'm not happy to see
cc5 because I was hoping for B5 as
someone who was who is rooting for
ding's comeback to make the match uh
even more exciting I was hoping for a
three result game but I wouldn't
exaggerate the dangers for black hair
yeah so maybe not uh the move you wanted
to see a niche but not a bad move either
that's the conclusion and um yeah how do
we think white wolf reactive Bishop B5
doesn't lead to anything concrete a
chaos oh he's played it now he's played
it I I want to point something out to
anisha's point Rook d8 I thought
initially Knight A4 is very strong just
kind of surrounding the queen size
because but I think there might be 96 to
C7 the retreating night moves are so
easy to miss and suddenly I feel like
black takes over the initiative because
Queen takes C5 and possibly drop a piece
black just takes the queen and takes the
bishop and E3 is hanging so why does the
one who wants to fork with Knight A4 but
then black is the one with a double
attack after going Knight C7 this is
really easy to miss
awkward Night Moves they're always the
trickiest ones
um
yeah do you think that I mean surely it
would be on uh neponishi's radar before
he plays a move like Knight A4 um I
think we're expecting you're not so sure
Daniel
I I think he'll see it in a world
championship match the world number two
player but hey I am known to jinx even
the best players so I'm gonna just
abstain from this conversation because
I've done enough damage already
and uh yeah I'm sure ding here after a
bit of thought will play Rook d8 as we
mentioned uh the alternative didn't look
too convincing looking with Bishop D7 so
um yeah uh people are mentioning in the
chat I met I saw uh the clock usage the
clock times it is move 18 or it will be
ding's 18th move and uh he spent just
over an hour if he plays the next two or
three quickly then he'll still have
almost an hour left for 20 moves that's
roughly how you should apportion your
time
um
so yeah you start with two hours of 40
moves if you use one hour for the first
20 it's fine so as long as he speeds up
slightly I'm still not too pessimistic
about his chances on the clock and it
does feel like the position is becoming
more concrete so the decisions will be
slightly easier at least over the next
few turns for ding
well I should add David that uh you did
the math slightly unfair there because
you are always team spending time of
course
but it is not exactly one hour 20 moves
one hour for the year 20 moves because
of course you start with the opening
where you play a few moves instantly
it's not exactly that I do think he
spent a little a little too much time
but uh that being said it's a position
he's familiar with it's a pretty solid
structure I think clock will not be the
main issue and I'm really curious to see
whether Yan will be able to put some
pressure here whether he'll be able to
create something
and uh besides I I want to take a look
at Bishop D7 once again because Bishop
D7 is a very uh principled way of
playing trying to trade these Bishops
which would probably benefit black uh
using the defensive task and I want to
see how that A4 because Knight A4 is a
move I was shocked to see uh I didn't
really see this idea of Dania of course
very very sharp I just want to take a
look at this position just to let it
sink in and see if there is not uh a uh
it defense here for for black because if
there would be then Bishop design would
be justified and I think this is what
ding is looking at are there really no
country sources here
for example for example uh I could it is
a bit crazy all right I could go CD
Knight B6 Queen D6 Knight HDE and I will
re I will be able to uh regain uh the
um the night but I will probably lose
the
the E3 Pawn so I'm not sure if that's
all operation makes sense
this is very complicated and Niche
suddenly it could go either way uh I'm
sure for example an engine would say
white is doing okay here why is extra
material uh these black pawns can be
stopped in the center but from a human
point of view this is very tempting now
situation
[Music]
especially because my idea is that if
you attack my E3 Pawn I'm going to go
for D4 I will not bother to take your
knight so I I want to see that uh so
this is one thing maybe after night
before there are some other ideas
because uh
okay we have to first before you go Rook
date which is a backup we have to
establish that this doesn't work for
black because if it does you rather Play
Bishop D7 then Rook d8 because Rook d8
anyway your idea eventually will
probably be to trade off this bishop on
B5 right with the sound hmm
yeah you're slightly cramped as black so
it makes sense to exchange pieces if you
can but uh yeah I mean this one is very
complicated does ding invest
20 minutes uh here on an idea like C
takes D4 sacrificing his rook in the
corner when he could just play Rook d8
very comfortably and no immediate
consequences even a tantra will addict
like me doesn't advocate for a long tank
here when you have a relatively healthy
option
especially the fact that he already is
down on the clock uh
and in DT plays Rook d8 yeah well if he
had a half an hour more he could invest
10 minutes standing in that position
looking for complications but when you
already are down you don't want to
potentially waste that time because it's
very likely you find nothing after night
A4 you very likely to review the CD4
idea which is a little bit Wicked
um which probably doesn't work very
often I have this in my own games as
well I see an idea like that and I don't
even actually I don't manage to review
it but I just don't trust it and I just
don't go for it which is of course
always
um always always a Pity because you know
you want to know why you take certain
decisions but sometimes you just have to
rely on your intuition as well and uh
think looking at his own clock being
half an hour down plays a solid option
of Rook d8 now it's on the end to to
prove a small advantage that he might
potentially have here
and it's on yarn also to avoid the
tempting Knight A4 which runs into
Knight C7 so presumably Yan who is
chilling in the break room right now
will invest a little bit of time to
figure out the proper regrouping where
to put his Queen whether to put the
Knight on E2 to G3 a lot of questions to
be answered for both players Jan's got
more time to answer them he's up 30
minutes on the clock as ding making sure
to stay hydrated and weak will also stay
hydrated and we will do that by taking a
break ladies and gentlemen you are
watching game three of the 2023 p-day
World Championship we hope you're
enjoying our coverage and we will be
back with more action from ding nepo in
just a couple of short minutes
hi I'm Gotham chess and this is the
chess kid chessboard challenge
can I take you at the same time foreign
I think the world record is like 35
seconds or something
I still know how to do this
did I just get a world record that was
like 32 seconds
[Music]
thank you
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that
you're world champion and it's taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with the adventures there's
something wrong with it I believe in
when we're talking the 60s and 70s even
the 80s and 90s
you could see that the match format
produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um uh we got to grab this chance with
both hands because it's not going to
come by way
[Music]
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
Yana promise first world championship
victory in game two this has to be such
an amazing feeling
ding Lee Rand knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame whoa what have you
seen this move before what's happening
he has to definitely find the momentum
and recompose himself
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
welcome back to chess.com's coverage of
the 2023 fide World Championship we are
an hour and 48 minutes into game three
of this momentous and prestigious event
it's been a pleasure bringing you
coverage alongside my master anishkiri
and of course Grandmaster David Howell
it's been awesome and the game is Just
heating up we are 20 moves in and Yana
Pam Nashi has just made a very big
decision so let's jump right into the
game d takes C5 has been played
releasing the tension in the center ding
is recaptured with the queen and queen
to D2 Anisha I'll start with you is this
an attempt to bail out or is yon playing
more ambitiously than it looks
yeah Danny you just mentioned uh you
just called it heating up I think we are
about to see it cooling down I mean
D4 1890 494 Rook D4
I mean once you deepon for epon you
reach symmetry
and I don't think it's strange I mean
you guys were enthusiastic for white for
a while and I I can understand that I'm
of course traumatized by that easy draw
the ding reached against me in this
structure I believe that uh these
positions they are simply not uh they're
not too promising for white with the
pollen F3 I understand if I had a pawn
F2 I could circle around the D5 Pawn
forever and these positions I have
different kind of experiences but when
white has a pot on F3 and the E3 Pawn is
constantly weak it's really hard to uh
to get yourself to ever exploit a week
D5 pawn and
that is probably one of the reasons why
Yang doesn't even bother and allows the
it allows D4 I believe in general he was
caught someone off guard he was hoping
for ding to play the names of Defense
where he had some surely more exciting
ideas but he was caught someone off
guard misremembered his prep and at this
point he is happy to just
um offer a path um a path to a draw to
Dink and don't forget he is up half a
point there's no need to take any risks
so I expect actually the game to cool
down rather than heat up but maybe I'm
missing something after D4 let's see
what do you think David
uh that's the first move we calculate
right it's a forcing move
um it simplifies the matter and let's
dive in Let's uh check out
uh are we missing anything okay I'm
assuming a capture another capture
you have to take you have to
takes and after Queen F2 uh Bishop to
luckily there is no rookie a check
Knight on F6 guards that after Bishop B6
we just have to make sure that white
cannot exploit the pin uh between the
Queen the X-ray rather or you see the he
can exploit
I think Rook D1 and Knight E2
this is what I was that's what I was
worried that's what I was worried for in
Rook idea 92.
sharp so instead of Bishop E6 I have to
make another move perhaps because I do
maybe I should play Queen D6 and pinning
but then you grab the d51 so let me see
if I have a I have a good move here
there's lots of Queen takes D4 of course
it's gonna say you could see why black
might get slightly scared here sorry
could we take the full movie let's let's
take a look yeah the pin of course title
let's take a look at critics before you
of course we take squid yeah why did I
take with the Rook of course you take
with the queen yeah
yeah the rookie seven maybe try to
try to exploit uh
something uh get get a little bit active
but uh
this is not your usual seventh rank
situation uh once I get my Bishop only
six
you will uh yeah you will not be able to
to touch me
I guess I guess
yeah there's one active roof there is
some small potential for white if after
Bishop D7 let's say even if we trade
everything that you have a little bit of
a weak soft A5 Pawn I have some D files
or this maybe is small pressure for
white especially because uh the fact
that my Rook is more active and your
Pawn A5 is a bit weak so maybe bishop D7
allows small plus though yeah even here
the bar is convinced this is all right I
guess you quickly do some 95 Knight C4
followed by Rook C8 quick counter play
against the inside Pawns
at the same time in the starting
position that we have now in the live
board uh position I can also Play Bishop
D7 let's let's say I don't force the
matters I don't think this is much
either to be very honest
yeah it's unclear whether the D5 pawns
actually weaker than the E3 Pawn anyway
and if white needs to jump in with my D4
at some point this structure will just
become symmetrical without black needing
to force that issue
so yes and especially I believe if we uh
if we get to trade Queens as white
probably the D5 phone is weaker because
you can play King F2 defending the E3
Pawn with the King
but what happened in my game with ding
is that we never traded queens and at
some point I remember I actually even
played King F2 with the Queens on the
board but then he hit me uh on the
diagonal with like move like a queen C7
at some point and somewhere he pushed
the pawn to H5
and I remember I started getting nervous
about my king there so I think in this
kind of positions black has to keep the
Queens on the board and if he manages to
do so I think the pawns are well I would
still feel D5 might be a little weaker
but maybe they are more or less equally
weak so yes a choice for ding um I have
to say it's very tempting to go D4 and
uh get rid of your weakness but uh even
if not I think uh position is very close
to be more or less completely balanced
and White's Advantage if anything is
just very symbolic
yeah what decision do you think uh would
most suiting right now in the match
situation the way he's been feeling uh
which one would suit his style more
suffer slightly potentially with Richard
D7 what if not suffer at least prolong
the tension uh keep the game going or
try and solve it here and now
mathematically with D4
um an issue might differ on this I I
feel like D4 is I don't want to say D4
is a must I but I feel like D4 is the
most concrete way to solve problems
Bishop D7 to me intuitively feels Bishop
takes D7 and Knight T4 I I don't see the
upside and I feel like D4 just decides
things he does Play Bishop D7 so he
waited for me to say this as usual
yeah no Daniel I I think the reason me
uh the reason me you David and Dingle we
have like two different opinions so
there is you and David who clearly
feel the white is some pressure if if
you know if we keep the status quo but
me and Dink we are maybe influenced by
the game that I had against each other
that game I I was not pressing at all
like I really got nowhere if anything at
some point I was already happy it was
all over because I was also playing very
slowly
so I think that uh me and ding we are
under influence of that game and we feel
that if the position just remains
neutral if uh nothing happens then black
is just very comfortable and I don't
know which which Camp is more right you
um Daniel and Davis or me and ding uh
which Camp maybe we are too biased with
with dink maybe uh that game you know
confused both of us the white is
actually slightly better but uh whatever
it is I'm sure being so D4 I'm sure he
saw he could probably hold it but I
think he thought that that position is
slightly worse
and uh
he thinks that this one is just fine
it's just fine and uh it will it will be
up to Yan to show uh
who is right here uh whether Jan will
put any pressure here I honestly uh
don't think this kind of position suits
Yan I don't think he has a lot of
experience playing against isolated
Queen side pawns uh he plays one E4 the
pawn is never on E3 it's already only
four after move one
so uh I don't I don't see why he would
uh
why he would be an expert in this Pawn
structure with black he's also played
the Greenfield his entire life he never
faced these kind of positions while ding
has a lot more experience with these
structures I think ding will easily
easily hold this game today at the same
time I don't think he will get
active counter chances because if white
plays it carefully
um there is just no way for black to
take over so I do expect basically I
think Jan is not too ambitious here I
think he does understand the position
very well and I think he just thinks it
looks quite equal and uh yeah I think we
are going to see a solid game now on
and Dania and anisha's dissing us here
he's uh they're showing us why we're not
top 10 in the world
but it's
the thing is the Moorish it shares his
insights on the position the more I
realize that the E3 Pawn is just such a
devastating is the wrong word it's not a
devastating weakness is a long-term
weakness and it really it settles you
because you just okay you put a knight
on D4 and I always feel like this
happens even in Blitz Games and I play
very good players against an iqpl put a
knight on D4 because that's what I was
taught and then I just reach a dead end
because the D5 Pawn it's isolated but
it's simultaneously very very well
defended the other reason I thought
white might have a minuscule iota of an
advantage is again that B5 Square the A4
square there's a slightly weak Square
complex on the queen side so I could
Envision a scenario where white let's
say takes on D7 and plays Knight D4 and
then maybe goes Rook E1 to C1 and the
last thing I'll point out and David I'll
pass it back to you is that after Knight
takes D4 he takes D4 I think it's easy
to be fooled by the symmetry of the
structure but that pawn on F3 as one
Robert Hess would be quick to point out
is fully restricting the mobility of the
white could stick a rook on E5 even this
I think is closer to equality and then
to anything else maybe black and
pressure the D4 upon but still I would
prefer white here if I had to choose a
side I would definitely take White your
thoughts
yeah I completely agree I would take
white hair but it is a stylistic thing I
do recognize that if we backtrack to
this position there's maybe two ways of
equalizing
um this one is more direct I think maybe
just uh because I'm always in time
trouble I want to resolve the tension I
want to kind of force the issue I want
to calculate my way to the end goal
which I guess here for black is equality
whereas Bishop D7 is a Karma move where
players trust the fact that actually the
position is dynamically balanced anyway
if any problems arise later they will be
solvable so um yeah I'm not saying
either move is better than the other but
uh yeah just a matter of taste so ding
does in the end go for Bishop D7 and
we're yet to see a reaction
I do expect as you mentioned uh Daniel
and yeah maybe just to either trade
Bishops or maybe jump in first with the
Knight to D4 I'm not sure if there's a
big difference
um I was wondering initially whether for
example after a trade whether I could
slide across and only put a knight on D4
when you can take back with a piece but
it does give black a very important
Tempo
um I'm wondering how to use that maybe
this uh kind of counter play we
mentioned earlier starts coming in at
some point
um either way Jan has choices he has
options in the current position
yes I think uh I like Knight D4 first
because if you do take on D4 ed4 and you
make a move like Queen D6 and these kind
of positions
I I think especially when we keep light
Square Bishops on the board and I get
Bishop on D3 they could be a little bit
of a white but I do also wonder uh
if it's not an optical illusion because
the thing about this queen side I
understand uh Daniel mentioned and I
also thought at first when I had that
game that you know he also has also has
a weakness on B5 but the thing is when
black at some point will prepare this B5
push once I get B5 before I will have a
strength for the weakness and at the
same time if you prevent it with A4 then
you will have a weakness on before which
is at the very least as important if not
more so I think it could be some sort of
an obstacle illusion that black is worse
in a position like this because this
weakness of B5 effects
it's not exactly a weakness and we see
young trading the Bishops uh the less
ambitious uh
way to to go and after root D7 Rook D1
and B5 comes to mind also a move like
Rook to E8 comes to mind as well when
after Knight D4 you have to uh yeah you
have to constantly worry about your E3
Pawn
oh he took with an what nice he took out
the night
what so very I guess he wants 95 he
wants 95 Knight C4
oh yeah spicy
really spicy a lot by the way is butter
is a little bit but it's a little bit
down it's a little bit like liking black
here or what
was Bishop takes Bishop an inaccuracy
wow
unexpected young completely missed this
move look at his uh he's getting into
the closer to the board he missed it
okay what if not before though I don't
how can white be worse I mean Knight D4
why should I be worse it doesn't look
worse at all
96 Fe you want to be better there
why not we're gonna have a monster night
on C4
I don't know you're we I don't like the
structure with the softball on E6 uh
weak Square on G6 as well
it looks soft to me I have all these old
games of of course in this old games of
Casper of karpov Whitehead light squared
Bishop which was exploiting it so I
understand where you're coming from
but I wouldn't allow Knight takes E6 as
black but it's also possible
I mean I think the position yeah I'm
very surprised that the bar would say
that black is uh black is better I think
that is overstating it uh certainly the
players don't feel this way after night
before I think they would think that the
position is around equal but it's a very
good showing of good show of alertness
there by ding with Knight takes D7 he
showed that you know he's also he played
quickly he showed that he is tactically
alert and Knight takes D5 is an illusion
of a threat it's not really a threat
because of Knight B6 I assume maybe just
winning am I winning a piece there
actually
looks that way pin on the D file
identify if there is quintex E3 at the
very least so 97 is clever indeed at The
Rook the seven that Knight on F6 was a
problem piece uh even what you mentioned
after Knight d494 Ed position is not too
bad but the knights on F6 is uh
dominated by the X reports 197 very
clever now Jan is rapping is uh is uh
you know forehead with his hands
thinking deeply about uh about the
consequences of what of his last
decision and after Knight D4
I think 94 should come because otherwise
95 or 96 heading to C4 would really
become a problem I think it's time to
offer symmetry with Knight D4 and ask
black whether uh whether black wants to
take some significant risks or just take
on D4 going for position that's uh looks
pretty equal
well Knight takes D7 that was a
statement move by dangling around the
retreating Night Moves we talked about
them in a different context
um ding turning on computer models
speaking of computers preparation as a
whole for the world championship has
greatly evolved with the Advent of
computer chess and nepo has risen to
prominence uh in you know the sort of
first computer generation I sat down
with Jan a couple months ago and asked
them how these lines affect the way that
he plays let's listen in to Jana
publishing
I wouldn't say uh I'm like
someone who could call himself like a
child of you know computer error I think
maybe I'm
Still Still belong to you know to let's
say more or less okay this mixer
generation who's
who started actually playing Just
without computers but okay later on
after achieving some level already you
can't you can't really think of playing
chess without like checking lines and uh
you know actually right now you can just
check clients with your with your iPhone
here so that's uh that's probably enough
to to find the moment you know when you
blunder it but for me it was main mostly
about like checking the database and
learning same games and getting some
info about the openings especially for
the first time and of course like now
it's I don't know so maybe most of the
players that are just trying to play
like computers already because okay it's
by far the most effective way and
whenever you just see the computer lines
whenever you see the relations you I
mean I don't know about okay everyone
but the case for me I'm trying to
understand why is that so so that's why
you try to dig in deeper into the lines
it's not necessarily you're not
necessarily learning uh the relation but
you want to see the typical Maneuvers
and so on so that's
because normally before you would like
replace some games of great players and
see how do they play how do they manage
okay this or that piece but now you just
do the same with you know the first line
of the engine or the second line
Johanna palmnushi on his use of
computers and uh where computer
preparation figures in his overall World
Championship preparation we pulled up a
matchup card there nepo and ding are
from the same generation ding is 30.
nepo is 32 and that's the generation
which grew up having computers but not
having strong chess engines really until
they were maybe I don't know 15 or 20
that's when you know computers
essentially became unbeatable so I want
to get your guys's take on uh what nepo
had to say about computers
um Anish do you feel like at this point
people from nepo's generation are fully
reliant on computers or if you compare
someone like nepo with someone like
Arjun aragaisi for example uh would you
say that someone like Arjun is
substantively more reliant on engines
than someone from an older generation
like nepo and Nisha I'll start with you
well it's one of my favorite topics
Dania so you know you of
Unleashed uh you know Unleashed monster
I love uh talking about the influence of
computers on players and on players of
different Generations I was thinking
about it recently when I had the game
with one of the young players
and at some point I realized that this
young player is he has a very similar
thinking process to mine
and I thought how is that possible we've
grew up such different times and why why
are we so similar and then I realized
maybe it's not so much the generational
uh difference because you have to
realize that a lot of young players
they're getting lots of coaching they're
reading lots of books they're
recommended to read books uh and they
still read the same books you know about
the games of capablanca or alurkin of uh
Kasparov Fisher Tao and um whether you
are from the old generation or from The
Young Generation you still
are influenced very often by
old-fashioned old-fashioned ways of
learning chess books and games
and so I'm not sure about for example
Arjun in particular uh
uh I have the feeling Arjun is mainly uh
shaped as a player by playing online
Blitz a lot you know it better because
you are you okay as we know you are the
boss the bossofgess.com now the the big
uh the big number one across uh both
time control so you know better but I
have a feeling that Arjun played a lot
as a young as a young player online I'm
not sure he spent a lot of time with the
engine actually go cash famously hasn't
spent much time with the engine at all
what has he been doing instead I guess
he's been reading books and studying
games of players while uh me myself
Adriano and Wesley we are much older
than kukesh but we must have spent a lot
more a lot more time um with the engine
so I'm not sure there is a generational
shift there I think it would be very
interesting just like at some point uh
the deepmind team decided to build an
engine that is free of the human games
and of human nonsense to build up to
create a player who would not learn any
classical games would not uh watch any
human games but would just learn from
the engine and see how strong that human
player would become but we are so far
um we are not there Nobody Does it as
soon as a young player is taunted he
immediately gets coached by some old guy
uh like uh great Vladimir kramnik or
polish girlfriend who tell these young
guys that okay you know you have to know
your Classics and we we ruined this pure
experiment and uh and in the end
everybody ends up studying the same
classical games so I'm curious what uh
Davis thoughts are on this topic but I I
don't I don't know if there's any
generational difference there per se
foreign
to agree in general Anish I think uh the
kind of the young players who do rise to
the top from this kind of younger
generation they have quite a broad
um education anyway they do have easier
access to resources than uh previous
generations for example and they know to
do the right things they're given good
advice but I do think that uh the Young
Generation who have grown up uh with
stockfish available for example there
are more pitfalls I know a lot of
youngsters who get carried about Away by
evaluate evaluations they see a position
they say okay this looks like plus one
this looks like plus two but actually
their own understanding doesn't improve
um they're just trying to rely on
memorization they're trying to rely on
kind of tactics that the computer shows
without kind of explaining it to
themselves and yeah I grew up with the
same generation as Yan as Magnus as all
these guys of course and um I'm looking
back and I've analyzed some of our
childhood games our openings were
terrible compared to uh the kind of
young generation nowadays partly due to
the effect of chessival uh but I think
we learned from our own mistakes we
learned from uh kind of we learned a lot
about our own style styles and
preferences and and so on quite early on
and uh that definitely helps and uh I
don't think it's a uh kind of
coincidence that for example Magnus
Sergey kariakin Fabiano Carolina and uh
Jan now anding all from the same
generation and all still up there
despite the emergence of the youngsters
um so yeah I'm terrible still using
technology on uh unlike you Anish I
really don't enjoy analyzing with
computers too much
um I tried to play anti-computer chess
these days uh just to avoid my opening
my opponent's preparation but yeah if
the young players use them wealth and uh
definitely a great tool to have and it
has influenced kind of yan in recent
years he's made this big push since his
openings got better since uh I think
he's figured out how to use these new
tools at his disposal
um and yeah he's uh he's up against ding
who I guess grew up a couple of years
younger maybe engines played more of a
role in his development but uh still he
has the human touch he's uh clearly got
that solid style that he's developed
himself over the years
totally co-sign your point David earlier
about uh just the state of openings
which isn't great now for me but looking
at my games from you know 2005 2006 uh
man I mean like three or four moves of
theory and then we're completely on our
own but recently I was in a bit of a
historical tangent
um realizing that it would be a mistake
to say that openings you know were not
taken seriously in the pre-computer era
I was surfing through mikhil chagoran
who was uh the top Uh Russian player
before uh the emergence of the Soviet
Union from the late 1800s he published
the first Russian language chess
magazine and in that magazine in every
issue he had an opening analysis section
which he did himself and it would
usually be 15 to 20 pages of of
variations that resemble a modern
opening book and you think about how
much time that took to produce without
you know without anything just he's
sitting there with a board and you know
a paper and a pen and he's writing up
all this crazy analysis on the king's
Gambit and the lines are going up you
know move 20. so the approach was
serious but now the volume of
information that has to be consumed has
exponentially risen with chessable and
engines and of course the objective
value of all that analysis is much much
higher now with with engines confirming
everything
and as we've been talking nepo has made
a decision uh Anish and it is in fact
Knight D4 and dang wasting no time
responding with ip6
computer computer it's the first line of
the engine
and uh well
I had this small uh moment of bias at
first because you know I don't like the
spawn on E6 and Poland H6 but as I
mentioned white doesn't have light
squared Bishop so I changed my mind
completely 96 F6 Knight C4 is coming
Knight B6 is even better than night on
E5
or some okay for obvious reasons Knight
is less vulnerable there and also it
keeps an eye on the A4 Square
you know what could happen here because
I see the bar already favoring black I
can easily imagine that Jan uh would be
completely oblivious to the dangers here
I know Jana is a very optimistic player
even I myself I wouldn't necessarily
realize that I can already be slightly
worse I couldn't I would think why am I
slightly worse well how how I mean what
why why what Sunday was
so especially if Jana is not aware of
the dangers here
yet he sees Knight C4 coming
you know it could could backfire for Jan
I mean I could easily see it going wrong
and there are some concrete threads to
the White Queen size after Knight C4 the
queen side is quite vulnerable and
think playing quickly and confidently
the clock situation also evening out
you know today
could could be a good day for ding lyron
let's see
yeah but if Yan wants to pull the brakes
uh he did kind of Grimace slightly
before he left the board if he wants to
pull the brakes it feels like there must
be a way right should we try and figure
out a path to safety for white yeah made
that face with Knight D4 uh sort of like
okay fine draw you know but uh
where is the draw now okay he was sort
of implying okay I was I thought I'm
better but it's fine now I'll give you
the draw okay how do you no no
I I don't see it so it's a good question
so breaks indeed I don't see
um I'm not saying white is losing no not
but in terms of breaks I don't see the
brakes I don't see how to simplify the
position further
I just don't see it uh we cannot trade
the E point for deepon anymore after 96
F6
we cannot trade the Queens uh so easily
maybe Queen D4 but is that really breaks
or is it just going for a slightly worse
end game after Rook C8 takes takes a
knight coming to C4
so I'm I don't think there are there is
a way for white to force a draw at this
point but I guess just playing
reasonable moves should still be solid
enough
uh to maintain some sort of equilibrium
but the computer evaluation you know the
computers are good as we discussed
already if they say Black's better I
mean Black's better
yeah
David I don't know what lines are
circling your head just really quickly
I'll share the line that keeps circling
around in my mind which is if you go
Rook D1 after Knight C4 Queen F2 I think
Knight takes a three
is mighty annoying because Knight A4
looks like a clever move oh let's
counter-attack the queen but no Queen
before and black maintains the extra
Pawn so that's one way that white could
very easily dig himself into an
objective hole now you'll be down upon
uh and and there's other lines that are
problematic as well
yeah plenty of other lines uh Rook D1
looks like a stabilizing move but
actually it does weaken E3 as well so
some tactics there potentially
yeah I'm on the same page as a niche I
just don't see a way uh to kind of go
into reverse gear and say okay let's
equalize let's draw this one
is concrete I think if I um had the
night on E2 already let's say Knight C2
I would probably be slightly better but
uh I think the problem is that after
Knight C4
um
it's just there's just no comfortable
comfortable move
and I I would still try to take on E6
first to try to try to create some
weaknesses in Black's position instead I
was looking at 96 fe6 and now maybe now
92 but then again after Knight C4
I was trying to make some Queen
if or perhaps work yeah but then 92
makes no sense and even Rook seat so
yeah I
I also I don't see f96 F6
how to deal with the threat of Knight C4
Knight A3 in a way that is uh prideful I
mean of course I can play even a move
like net B1 I dealt with that threat
it's not it's not the problem the
question of how to save the pawn it's a
question of how to save the pawn while
keeping the pieces on good squares and
that is a harder task
how bad is this end game you mentioned
trying to get rid of the Queens
uh yeah maybe that's the least uh the
list of
the evils maybe okay ac8 or
um
that's why well I don't know if I can
keep the Queens on anymore
um I was thinking of going to try and
pressure these pawns but it's just a one
move threat yeah and you know the thing
about end games is once you enter an end
game then the weakness of the E6 and G6
squares while not relevant anyway uh
without the Queens it is not an issue at
all because this is a minor weakening of
the king side and of the king safety and
so once the Queens are off it's already
becomes clear that this this is already
visibly better for black here I can
already see it because of course the
fact that Knight C4 is coming is um
is an issue in an end game and the fact
that the king side is somewhat weakened
is irrelevant completely so I would
somehow keep the Queens on the board as
white to sort of
you know when you are slightly worse
there are two types of slightly worse
there's a slightly worse where it's
visible to everyone that you're slightly
worse
and there's a slightly worse where it's
kind of a dynamic slightly worse so you
have trumps he has trumps but your
trumps are less than his trumps
but when you have this kind of slightly
worse the opponent might not even
realize that he's better because he
might assess your trumps as bigger than
his or equal to his and so you might get
away with uh you know it's something
this way so when you're slightly worse
at first you try to not make it obvious
that you are slightly worse if that
makes sense you know what I mean until
until at some point the opponent plays
so well sooner or later you have to
transition into a Wars end games like
that
there's a lot of Trumps you mentioned
that Anish
yeah difficult position
for white either way and it in terms of
talking about small disadvantages it's
not really Yan style to suffer in one of
those uh kind of let's get the Queens
off and try and grovel type of
disadvantages it would be very much his
style to okay be worse but at least look
the counter chances keep some attention
and I think we're struggling to find
those types of positions either and uh
so is Heath judging by his clock usage
over the last few moves
um maybe it's starting to settle in now
the common uh of course common theme
that the pawns A3 B2 are hit by Knight
C4 because if the A3 Pawn was on A2 I
would be able to respond with B3 kicking
the knights away but now after B3 the A3
Pawn is hanging so white ended up in the
situation uh because of the spawns and
you know it's quite interesting that we
were talking about the weakness of the
B5 Square which was apparent but it's
now turned around on white suddenly
white spawn Queen side pawns are a weak
and uh
yeah it is just remarkable how
complicated chess can be sometimes that
I mean in a position which looks
slightly better for white at the start
right you guys were saying why slightly
better I warned you of course but you
didn't listen and uh
now we are on the defensive you know but
we're welcome to six Niche
I would say that I think if Jan finds
like one or two I was thinking about
them of rookie two you know one or two
solid calm defensive moves it still
feels like he should be well within the
general range of equality
um so I was thinking rookie two Knight
C4 Queen D3 and then it's very important
I think that Knight takes E3 fails two
Knight takes E6 hitting the sort of the
tail of the discovery and then you take
the Knight with with the queen
um so if that doesn't work and perhaps
white could potentially bring the other
Rook over to D1 and solidify that Knight
and if you can get black to take on D4
okay black maybe has a tiny pull because
of the superior Knight but that is
something I think nepo would be more
than happy to to finish off defending
yeah I liked Ricky too as well but uh
here uh what if Rook ac8 after 23 I
don't think I want to take on D4 I think
that will easen your uh task a lot
you'll open bunch of files so here how
do you deal with the thread of Knight V2
right now
well
night is 902 really for Rook D1
okay
it's also Knight A4 yeah 394 yeah
well make a move anyway make a move okay
Rook D1 Rogue one okay
and that'd be two you are you're
claiming that we'll just will I won a
five and Rook D5
yeah
um
yeah go a little bit maybe everything
and I was thinking well Rook B7 I
thought first maybe but
but yeah Knight F5 too I agree white is
suffering for sure no question about it
yeah something like this is of course
possible and maybe good and this is
probably how white should play trying to
seek for a secret draw in this kind of
complications but obviously here uh I
mean obviously black is slightly better
just a question as if uh if it's a draw
or if there is something more to it I
mean a black is moment at the moment um
upon up even though a bunch of pawns are
weak it's only black that plays for
Advantage but yeah something like this I
guess is the way to play just keep put
Rooks uh on good positions rookie two
Rook D1 allow us at some point Knight
takes B2 and try to salvage a uh Savage
draw there that that sounds right about
right to me much better than the
approach of going like Knight D1 and
trying to go everything back and try to
defend because that's how you really get
into trouble
active defense yeah makes sense I was
also wondering about kind of using these
squares
um sorry
perhaps the most natural move now I
realized yeah
this is the first move on my radar just
to kind of connect these nights and hope
that the White Queen covers it covers
the rest of the mess covers all the
pawns but again it might be slightly
uncomfortable uh for example if black
kind of cements at some point the Knight
on C4 you're still a bit stuck with
white it's unclear you ever want to
resolve the tension and
um yeah I could imagine this one being
uh
at least psychologically or
aesthetically difficult for Yan to go
for
and look at this beautiful night of the
C4 uh actually even if I take on D4 and
go B5 the Knight of C4 it hits that weak
E3 pawn it hits the weak B2 pawn and
it's so so well protected there uh and
here we could definitely say that
probably white has more weaknesses than
black and the D5 Pawn is no longer under
any pressure with the Knight on C4 I'm
exerting a lot of pressure on the E3
pawn and keeping B2 Pawn in check I I
think this is nice for for black and
that even said I don't really have to
take on D4 yet uh keeping you know
keeping white Knights white Knights
attack attached to each other making it
hard for white to move so not a very
pleasant scenario I I think this rookie
took the one idea trying to bail out in
a slightly worse end game that is the
more class classy approach uh to try and
make a draw in a position like this
let's see if that's what Yan chooses
because Knight cp5 is a more prideful
way you try to
um you try to keep the isolated Pawn
blocked you you know you don't admit
that you are worse
but uh but when you are worse maybe it's
okay to admit it as well yeah
yeah difficult decision
yeah difficult decision and it's not
Yan's style to play a move like rookie
two uh really but uh he might have to
let's see if he goes for it and the
clocks are balanced out okay he plays
Rook D1 we mentioned this earlier and
Daniel pointed out that black could
potentially win a pawn
in some lines uh what do we think of
this move
this is
gonna happen
yep
only a logical move really uh maybe
maybe he wants queen C1
but that's very passive
this comes in the way of the C file I'll
bring the Rook to C8 put pressure there
I don't know I think I think into E2 or
F2 and after Knight A3 he has he has a
way to he thinks he has a way to somehow
maybe Knight F5 or
wow and okay we'll find out Daniel and
and like C4
take 25 yeah yeah so let's say queen F2
here in that case
let's put it on the board and if we take
this Pawn trying to undermine this
Knight on C3 then you want Knight F5 wow
or not interesting the evil that's the
important thing
yeah it's very human though going for
some checks wow
I think 965 cheaper this is nice 1930
but maybe
yeah just a short tactic I have another
crazy idea after after we finish with
this
the tactic this is what once uh what's
the crazy idea Daniel hit us with it
E4 instead of Knight F5 I'm sure the
evil bar will laugh
oh sure
oh
all right so many captures now it's so
tricky to calculate uh what should black
even try here comes with a complimentary
Advil yeah
well I guess uh I guess we should
simplify as black yeah maybe Knight
takes D4 simply
okay we're heading in this direction
between the Queens
equal end game pretty much
okay if anyone I think black is slightly
but Knight E3 let's say but I I don't
think it's much
yeah and the game goes on
um so this is the current position uh
after Queen to F2
by the way just make a make a move
into Tech of course I have to say
this is what we expected right Jan
defending actively with the help of
tactics
yeah it is there this Knight 884 this is
the kind of approach you should take in
a position like this and then just try
try and hope to simplify everything and
make the game Peter into a draw
let's see if dinker has really any
sensible alternatives on Knight A3 here
what is White's next move if let's say
Rook ac8 yeah it's the one you suggested
good question
I'm thinking about E4 anyway it doesn't
seem to work there because the Knight is
targeting B2
so
Knight F5 you already discussed but
that's a one move threat black and move
is King to H7 for example and what if
what is what accomplished
so yeah
as well
position uh here very subtle position
very unclear
um
1994 by the way is also some kind of
move the queen doesn't have that many
squares but maybe maybe
I don't know I kind of
the Knight on A4 is of course not well
placed but maybe I am misplacing your
queen somewhat
maybe not not so sure
did they not teach urination nights on
the side of the board nights in the room
it was when I was working with Vladimir
Kramer
before his candidates tournament in 2018
I had lost once very painful game to
live on and
early on I played 95 with black and he
just sent me a short message he said
like I said you know nice uh nights on
the rim like night on the rim is dim or
something yeah I mean you know I'm
trying we're trying to be top players
here you know trying to play trying to
think deep stuff and while you're coming
just tells me you know don't put in the
horse at the age of the world
as they say
yeah it's conventional wisdom for a
reason I guess but uh yeah it might work
93 very tempting I mean when you have a
tactical opportunity that that is where
you don't risk anything as well
because I don't think black risks in any
of these variations it's very hard to
resist it
because you think okay if I don't do it
now maybe I'll never get this
opportunity and also what's the words
that can happen okay if white finds some
drawings someone who can get some end
game that's fine by me as well I'll be a
good deal is so I think Knight A3 are
very likely very likely to follow
um I don't know also from the possible
moves I mean I can play A4
uh trying to you know cement cement
something
I'd like to look around just yeah
control
yeah just trying to establish what I
don't like slightly is I I wish I could
also go B5 so I cannot follow it up with
B5 but maybe A4 alone is um
if we're alone is good enough
and sort of give way to move and ask
because now after A4 I suspect Knight A3
maybe it's a bigger bigger than before
yeah yeah
oh sorry I was just gonna say things go
43 minutes how I mean it makes sense to
invest it now right where there's
actually something to calculate uh he's
played very quickly
17 moves to the time control
uh for him yeah 10 minutes so 10 minutes
thought is very appropriate here I guess
especially as Knight takes A3 is the
opportunity to you know unsettle the
game and get something tactical going
definitely tempting there and but you do
have to calculate the consequence of 93
what are the what are the possible
options other than E4 is it 3D E4 the
only move to somehow make sense of it
yeah that makes sense now it takes we
were struggling for options other than
uh and yes E4 there maybe 96 and E4 but
I don't know if that makes sense
you know considering that the
immediately for
exists
yeah we are always in this kind of
moments we are kind of hoping the ding
will make his move so that we will be uh
you know this we'll see in which
direction the game goes because it's
these are two fundamentally different
directions it's either Knight A3 or it's
not Knight A3
and uh but I do think the dink will uh
take a moment here
you will take a moment maybe we can make
some moves on the on the analysis board
and try to Deep dive this uh Knight F3
possibility here
sorry well I think we're actually going
to go perhaps on a short break first
um and and kind of letting ponder it
and when we come back we will hopefully
have some clarity on which direction the
game goes if ding continues to think we
can dive into Knight takes A3 something
tells me that he will play Knight takes
C3 but uh we are gonna refill our coffee
cups folks you're watching the feed 8
World Championship 2023 we'll be back
with more ding versus nepo in just a
couple of short minutes
thank you
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
Mike Klein for chess.com here in Astana
Kazakhstan where they're experimenting
with a new technology these Street
crossing signals are wired to the dgt
boards for example this means white is
winning and then uh oh a slightly
imperfect move now it's not so clear uh
what's gonna happen oh huge Thunder by
white so you can actually track the
games while walking around the city
we'll see how this goes
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
2023 fide world championship between
nepo and ding Lee ran World Quant is an
official partner of the chess.com
broadcast of the fide World Championship
they are a global firm that builds
complex mathematical models to identify
market inefficiencies now World Quant
brain is bringing together its
International Quant championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chess player
right if you think you have what it
takes register for the international
Quant championship at togo.chess.com iqc
or use x Clem iqc in chat International
Quant Championship keep it in mind and
we hope you're keeping round three of
the world championship match in mind
Grandmaster David Howell Grandmaster
Anish girian JM Daniel nerdinski
bringing you coverage of this
fascinating game as ding tries to make
his way out of a one point deficit and
we've got a couple of moves Anish I'll
start with the I'll let you guide us
through the last uh three moves
well apparently uh David dink just like
me was unaware of the fact that Knights
on the rim are dim so he or or other
young actually was unaware he plays the
1984 and um
well the advantage it had is that it
kicks away Black's Queen from a very
juicy position and it also removed the
knight from a very shaky position on C3
so after Queen E7 which was natural uh
young played rookie one and now
I think let's play Queen F6
interesting the queen is sort of making
a round not sure about the last move
Queen F6 I think there were a lot of
options I don't know why it came so
quickly but I guess he also has not
zoomed too much time he has to watch his
clock a little bit instead of Queen F6
there are many interesting Alternatives
there I believe
which ones caught your eye and each
queen of six looks very natural to me
gets off the uh e-file now that the
white Rook is sitting there putting some
pressure on D4 I guess uh some tactics
potentially against B2 long term
more concrete
yeah I mean I I'm not sure if it's good
but it was an option of Queen E8 uh
attacking at the Knight and then
I might try to win a pawn
not sure if it's good of course because
I'm somewhat uncoordinated here but
that's nice city I have Knight A3 maybe
I'm always obsessed with this 90k idea
like a little child who knows he's a
cheap cheap and get it out of my head
maybe neither five now is a little bit
more effective than it used to be
it looks very nice for Whitening the
blacks pieces are not too active so
Queen F6 uh very natural very natural
Queen is much better place on F6 than it
is only eight of course guarding this F5
Square also eyeing the bit on probably a
decent decision
already a move
wow
yeah this is counter-intuitive so I'm
surprised he played it so quickly of
course yeah I'm very quick player but
um yeah these Knights they look clumsy
to me I've got to admit they're both
kind of on outposts but what are they
doing I need to stop laughing because
they're making me laugh
I'm sorry why are you laughing no I'm
laughing because you're laughing I was
out oh no no David's laughing
okay speaking of the knights um
I do like them
[Music]
I don't like them a lot
interestingly they both walked out of uh
being you know they sort of moved away
from being attacked so they've and
they're very comfortable now on these
two squares as the black queen has
transitioned uh from C5 to F6 the
knights are kind of
and somewhere Untouchable there
and um they're looking out for each
other you know the knights on B5
prevents the move B5 which would hit the
A4 Knight the looking out for each other
and
I don't know I think as long as there's
nothing concrete
white should be doing okay okay here
um I liked public this b5a4 kind of
ideas to try to grab some space from the
queen side but now that's out of the
question still not sure about Queen F6
after all
not sure if that was uh that was such a
good good Square maybe a move like
Knight C7 comes to mind trying to trade
away the B5 Knight so that later you can
push B5 and and gain some space on the
queen side after all fight for this B5
Square maybe 9c7 doesn't feel too
ambitious I guess why it has multiple
ways of equalizing there
maybe some even some takes and uh
93 or some all kinds of ideas
not to um not too thrilling I don't know
what are the most come to mind David
maybe oh maybe H5 H4 also some some idea
to not sure if H5 H4 is actually
anything I can just play H3 and prevent
any control play right it's okay trying
to generate something on the king side
perhaps
yeah I'm also wondering if white at some
point can start annoying harassing those
black Rooks kind of kick away from good
squares with like Knight to A7 on the
topic of knights on the room being dim
uh Knight to A7 so in certain situations
might uh might be a bit annoying
um yeah I'm trying to look for logical
moves for black and it's not intuitive
to me I was also looking at exchanging
one of these Knights either 95 or Knight
C7 uh just trying to get rid of one set
but again it feels odd kind of logically
to trade off a really nicely centralized
night for one of these two on the side
of the board that's how to improve
I don't want to centralize my Queen but
again is it necessarily that good there
it just feels like a random move that
I'd make in a ton of scramble or in
Blitz
yeah it is sorry if you like any ideas
uh you can always try to improve your
position with moves like G6 ninja 7 I
mean that's a go-to go to waiting move
but uh I would think that um if that's
the best you have at this point that
probably you don't have
too much pressure and why it's next
moves I mean
do you want to bring one of the knights
back with Knight AC3 or you want to
double with Rook D3 rookie D1 one of
these two I guess
something to do with the D5 Pawn right
putting it under pressure
yeah I my queen G6 caught my eye for
some reason but I can't fully flesh out
why
maybe to stop
yes when you're spotting spotting this
cheaper potential that you already see a
future where yeah
exactly yeah but it's not a threat
yeah yeah but but you usually how you
how you guys you know you dirty people
who are always uh tricking me uh you
guys set up these tricks you know moves
in advance and you know that one day I
will blunder Knight B2 so you're setting
it up in advance I appreciate that very
very uh very clever cunning idea
it makes some sense as well 95 yeah
Knight D3 coming in like multi-purpose
why not at least float the idea kind of
put the fear of ghosts into the opponent
exactly
yeah uh at Blitz it would be very
effective at classical um
maybe less so but we'll see if there's
nothing else to do then why not Queen G6
to be honest
um and that is struggling to come up
there's a problem
uh AC3 and pressure on this Pawn
yeah and Daniel spotted 95.97 cheap as
well yeah so we are uh
yeah it works both ways the tactics can
work both ways so
we are not sure Queen G6 indeed uh
Knight AC3 might in general be an idea
for white
for the next next move so interestingly
why it's managed to rearrange the knives
so I think yeah I know Knight to seven
is kind of a
kind of a principle the move uh if you
ask me but maybe it's my wrong instinct
to try and clarify
position but I I kind of like this
Knight C3 uh I do like to
to fight for that B5 square and my idea
would then be to trade the Knight and
get this B5 on down the board
and reinforce my C4 Knight
yeah
makes a lot of sense so a big decision
right now for ding I doubt he would have
expected this might be five move and if
I played it very quickly
surprise probably because it does look
pretty good and harmonious it's 9p5 off
yeah and uh I was on his side ding with
the clutch kind of consumption there uh
he still has
nearly half an hour but suddenly
it could start to play a factor for the
first real time in this game uh we're
not yet at move 30 uh some big decisions
ahead this position still shows no signs
of uh fizzling out or no uh getting
clarified
there are some ghosts of course some
ghosts of uh of clarification after if
you imagine somewhere Knight C3 Knight
A3 some Knight D5 all this uh there is
Knight takes assemblance Knight C3 there
is some potential uh to see trades here
let's say uh how do I how do I start
I don't think Knight B2 or Knight D3
works because it's Knight D5 so I have
to actually protect D5 first
yeah
for sure first do I do it with uh Rook
cd7 or queen E5 or maybe Rook cd7 yeah
let's say
and um
it is possible that there will be some
simplification down the road or also of
course it's ability to have removed the
Rook from uh from the C file
but I wasn't sure if yeah maybe room T4
and here this looks actually very
comfortable for you so I should keep the
Rook on the C file to keep Knight A3
threads alive maybe Queen if
in E5 perhaps
a little bit more some missed something
there yeah but isn't there maybe E4
or 95.95
4.95
maybe F4 first as well because after E4
maybe there is Knight B2 or something
like that
um
but that would be the sort of scenario
where we do simplify a bunch of a bunch
of pieces so yeah I think a critical
decision there for dink 997 uh is uh is
kind of a way to to clarify things but
so far he's been keeping tension
continuously his every decision he's
been keeping tension so 97 would not be
in the spirits perhaps he's looking more
it moves like H5 G6 the simple moves
trying to slightly improve the position
Knight C7 on the board yeah
just as you called Anish but that final
position after the nitrate and just
retreating it did look quite promising
to White at least to me it just felt
like why it's got stability now this
Black Knight still looks nice and pretty
but big weakness to Target
um how kind of fine is the margin for
error here
a little
sorry 95 25
.
tactics Tic Tacs oh my god oh yeah
tell me
is it Queen G3 Queen takes G3 Knight F6
no it's not because Queen G3 Rook D5
Rook D5 and C7 hangs
okay I'm proud okay this is a I'm proud
to blunder that that's that's not a
shameful one I'm proud I'm proud yeah
this is a good blunder no I'm
you bring out the best in me
anishes that I'm like okay you got me
there I give you that we should show the
other line though with Queen G3 because
that's uh that's a nice one
it's by the way it's so sick that you
would actually blunder it in a real game
maybe not classical probably more rapid
or Blitz I could honestly I could see
myself blunder it like I honestly didn't
see what was wrong with my bits of Queen
E5 so that's a good one it's a very deep
this is typical Queen just it takes 96
that's International is a typical kind
of thing that uh even a reasonable
player can can blunder
watch this happen in the game that would
be insane
we have it insane but could happen
commentators curse strikes again you're
like his hype man Daniel oh sorry
anisha's like the hype man you set him
up and then Dania hits with the tactic
it's uh it's easy with the eval bar
maybe I could go Queen G5 not to to lose
after Knight D5 or he's already too late
says it's okay
no I couldn't just he doesn't hit the
queen anymore so I was not too much off
so Knight B2 actually is possible yeah
it's just my follow-up was bad
okay okay yeah this this yes
what is it has enough
after queen beetles
actually slightly better
wow Queen takes yeah of course but must
be so drillish but well E3 Pawn is soft
outside past pot potentially Maybe
take take A4 perhaps
very little of course I mean very Jewish
this stuff but against Magnus I'd be
changing my pants right about now I mean
if I had this with white against Carlson
I mean I would I would not be sleeping
peacefully
yeah just resign and go home here yeah
yeah you know how this is gonna end it's
some 75 move you know win with a zero on
this cross stable
yeah but meanwhile uh this long
variation perhaps both players are
calculating right um Jan is quite
forcing he's going to be looking at
Knight takes and Knight C3 what could be
more natural
I have all those cheap posts with my uh
with one of my friends because there is
the saying a wrong a long variation
wrong variation you know they're all
saying I think Larson maybe yeah
but you know that nowadays with the
computers a long variation not at all
wrong yes a long variation this is right
variation usually yeah so it's it
doesn't mean it doesn't have to be wrong
in this case and maybe that line we
showed is quite relevant in fact
but Knight C3 was uh not necessary we
plundered I mean not blundered we of
course didn't see that B2 at first so
after 97 Rook C7 you could probably make
a move first and then after uh on the
next one so it's a technique maybe Rook
D4 or something like that and d593
just post up on a nice Outpost and uh
yeah the tactics might work in White's
favor a bit later on
yeah I guess that long variation wrong
variation is more practical it's like
don't spend your time kind of
calculating 20 moves into the future
when you might make a slip up on the
first move or two as we did in that
variation yeah of course not but it's
it's like you know so many of these
sayings they first of all contradict
each other uh uh very often also not
only in chess but in life you for you
for every situation you have uh two
different sayings one that advises you
one thing and the other advice is the
the other and the same with just wisdoms
like there's usually uh it has to be
like applied very selectively so all
this uh smart uh smart wisdom and smart
saying is all just uh the old relative
um but that said we are slowly you know
the longer the players think the more
the harsher will be the time scramble uh
potentially so we are delaying you know
delaying the excitement but sooner or
later uh they will deliver some
excitement so uh to tell our viewers not
to worry we are a little bit bored right
now but soon we will get things will get
heated
yeah it definitely feels like we're
building up to something and uh we saw
ding uh leave the board there he's been
sitting mostly at the boards we
mentioned how about Yan does it look
like he's in calculation mode uh and he
must have sat opposite him countless
times
what's he trying to figure out right now
yes of course uh
definitely in his calculation mode he
has uh missed Netflix the seven earlier
on in the game let's just briefly point
out that moment once again the moment
where things got slightly out of control
so after Bishop D7 unassuming move he
could have played uh Knights to D4
out of 21 here I'll show in the um
analysis board later on but uh now uh
uh now already that uh yeah now that we
are here he is completely focused he
understands it's a three result game he
could also he could also get into some
trouble so he's trying to be very
accurate he has his thinking cap on and
look uh again is his posture with his
hand uh wraps around his forehead uh he
he is definitely uh focused and doesn't
want doesn't want to let his lead slip
away so quickly after having obtained it
so yes definitely a focus here and there
thinking about all the stuff we are
looking at it's not between at D5 I
think at some point he might spot 25
Queen G3 get very excited about it and
he was supposed to be in G5 so all the
things we were looking at
at some point in his head
yeah he's uh perfected the gelfand uh
peace well
um
what he's doing with the piece to to
what uh Boris is the art of Boris the
forest does it very differently Janice
twirling the piece the way I can also
twirl it with uh almost all of his
fingers what Boris does he holds the
piece with two fingers between the two
fingers and he
throws flicks it and it kind of makes a
it's the piece is free fall it's a very
different art what Boris girlfriend is
doing to how a young Sterling uh the
pawn I I wouldn't compare him to the art
of the you know
the art of that Boris uh uh Boris is
also able to throw a queen around which
is a very huge big piece which is really
difficult because playing with the pawn
is easy it's very small piano showing
now that he can also play with this
bishop that is also a commendable but
Tian try try grab that queen that is a
real challenge
[Laughter]
mesmerizing
isn't it
yeah and uh how about an inner monologue
because when I play these days I'm
always thinking to myself okay do I
really try and press here do I spend 10
minutes calculating there's often a lot
of kind of uh
arguing with myself about decisions is
he just purely calculating here how do
you guys do it when you're sitting at
the board in these situations especially
really tense uh with clock ticking
well well I'd go ahead and go ahead oh
go ahead first yeah because uh I am like
sometimes I am even thinking about
things outside the chess board so I'm
not trying to speak about but I want to
hear Daniel what is the chess.com
um leaderboard report number one how
does what is the thinking process of of
leaderboard number one notchess.com
please enlighten us well the only minor
Insight I had is uh there are situations
when you miss what I would call a minor
move like Knight takes D7 right it's not
a flat out blunder but it always puts me
on alert when I like mid completely miss
a recapture or I just assumed it was
impossible that already signals to me
that I'm probably not in the best
calculational form and I think almost
subconsciously when a moment like that
happens even if it doesn't objectively
impact the evaluation it definitely
makes me second guess subsequent
calculations and oftentimes I would err
on the side of caution uh when I'm
performing subsequent calculations so
nepo mess 1967 now the things have
gotten very complicated maybe he's
investing some thought into like Knight
C7 Rook C7 okay maybe avoiding Knight C3
maybe avoiding the most complicated of
the lines so you know maybe he's
operating with a little bit more caution
uh at least that's kind of what I tend
to do when I miss uh even even a
relatively minor move but back to a
niche uh the actual certainly
professional that makes sense makes
sense you know uh I would even add to
that besides this little blunders that
are not blunders what happens a lot is I
guess it happens to everybody sometimes
you blunder in your calculation so you
are about you you sort of included
something
and let's say you what you are about to
play Knight takes B2 9525 and then you
realize that you've almost blundered
Queen G3 and just blundering inside your
calculation could also definitely cause
that that same lack of
and use double guessing second guessing
yourself meanwhile Jan has played um has
made the move he was Knight D4 well he's
of course inviting a move oh wow oh
about this position any longer maybe
but even if he's not intending to repeat
moves uh we should mention to the
audience this is uh the second time
we've seen this position now the
knight's just doing a bit of a dance
even if ding isn't intending on going
for the draw it makes sense right just
to scope out his opponent's uh mindset
to at least gain well not gain time but
get quicker get closer to move 40. so it
makes sense from a lot of angles yeah
that's why he played it instantly as
well he if he does the second time
instantly that will be weird but of
course the first time he does it is
instant because with this move he gains
time and not only gets as one who has
less time on the clock of course
normally the person wants to get to the
time control earlier and uh he played
instantly trying to gain this extra
minutes Giannis away from the board and
he will think we'll really think twice
whether he wants to make a draw or not
but not just now on the next on the next
move yeah
yeah only if white plays Knight B5
maybe then he'll play Knight C7 anyway
but he has options of course it's not
forced yeah he will I think he will want
to play for a win after Knight D4
probably rather than after Knights uh
Knight B5 so he will play 97 94 and now
uh and then think and that in that
juncture
you're like he'll think and then go 96.
he'll like take three four minutes
that's what I used to do and I didn't
want my coach to accuse me of taking a
draw too soon I would basically spend
the rest of my time well like listen I
was inside I was in time pressure anyway
of course I had to take the draw
common that happens a lot so you have
like people they have like 40 minutes
against 30 minutes let's say and they
have in this situation and then they
drop to like 20 minutes and then like
yeah you know I had less time so I
decided to yep exactly because you spent
all your time on the last one this move
come on
yeah I think they've done that yes which
doesn't have to know that he doesn't
have to know when you spent that time
and Knight B5 immediately from Yan
um we I guess we're assuming now that
he's happy with the draw with white
it should be it should be uh I think
after he missed nights takes the seven
he already definitely realized that this
game he has to play it safe and uh
there's no reason not to because he's
still leading so the draw is completely
fine for him and it's if anyone is ding
that has to always second guess this
kind of decisions mm-hmm and the clock
could play a factor ding is 10 minutes
lower than his opponent uh should we
make some predictions is this going
uh is this going to continue or will we
see ding bail out and tell his coach he
was lower on the clock
well I predicted
yeah I think draw because it's it's not
the sort of like we didn't even identify
a specific alternative that just seems
to you know
the only attempting move that you
consider if you want to play for a win I
think he's the move B5 because that's
that's a pretty uh you sort of
um reconnect the pawns with each other
but I really don't think that it looks
better for uh for Black by no means nice
C5 or Knight C3
it looks maybe balanced sort of but I
don't see this as a reason to play on
with less time on the clock even Knight
C5 let's say yeah Knights five Knight D3
like
I mean winning this position is a very
very very very long way to go a little
less time on the clock thing not still
not very confident and the temptation to
end this game end this uh in a
reasonable way and then to press uh for
a win with white pieces after having
recovered from A Loss I think ding is
likely to repeat most here I'll be
surprised if he plays for a win but but
but I would respect that very much and I
would I would think that's that's that's
great but I wouldn't expect
and uh you said you'd respected it a lot
maybe he wants to make uh Jan respect it
and respect him for uh at least showing
courage and playing on I don't know how
much risk is involved there and each the
variation you showed for example uh is
black really risking that much after a
move like B5 yes white can move the
Knight
if it's like black has full stability
anyway
um
you don't read just now but uh if the
game goes on and you have less time
um you know things things can definitely
inspire a lot of control at some point
so wait well we'll see on the next move
after 94. it's 94 threefold because it
isn't the position reached three times
after Knight T4 or am I mistaken I don't
think the Knight doesn't C7 the first
time the night was on D4 the Black
Knight was on E6 the black queen was on
all right okay got it got it okay
but after 94 then up to ding he can
claim a draw or he can play B5 I think
that that is the critical point yeah
because indeed B5 indeed is also
reasonably stable
I don't like the Knight on C7 it's such
a passive night it's defending defending
the pawns but
it's such a passive Square from C7 the
knights can only jump to E6
from where it can then jump to C5 and
then enter White's Camp so you are
really far away from creating any
threats
it's hard for me to somehow imagine that
Ding will play for a win with a knight
on C7 like I mean you can go B5 foot
I don't know I I don't expect that
Knight D4 is on the board and now the
moment of truth will ding claim the draw
with 96 that is threefold he's looking
at a score sheet that's usually a pretty
pretty much a giveaway
it's a draw
and that is three-fold repetition
and the handshake is coming
no they gotta claim it yep
because until move forward you cannot
accept the drum so you have to claim the
three of faults but the arbitrary sharp
is right there uh yeah
yeah handshake
standard procedure would have been to
stop the clock right down the move uh
and to call the Arbiter but uh yeah
either way it was gonna be a draw and
what do we think a fair result a tense
game
yeah I think a wire to wire equal game I
think an important game for ding to
prove to himself that he can basically
draw without going through a worse
position he was in control of this game
maybe on move 17 we'll take a look at
look at it B5 was more ambitious than C5
but Anish I think definitely all things
held equal a confidence boost a solid
drop from a position of strength for the
black pieces
yeah for sure for sure as uh you know
thinking from a perspective of a ding
fan if I was one I definitely would fear
a knockdown so another loss and the two
loss in a row would be would be disaster
I really like also for Alex from the
start just the way ding looks today even
now he sits there you know with his arms
on the table and his talking is smiling
a bit
I just like how he looks I think he's I
think that loss it relieved the pressure
in some sense and I think he's got
plenty of time to come back you know we
just started we have so many rounds
ahead more than 10 rounds I think 11
rounds ahead of us and lots of
opportunities to bounce back and we saw
you know good play from today we also
saw an interesting opening choice I
think we will see this again I think Jan
will see this as an opportunity to get a
playable position with white so I think
we will see a repeat of this at some
point maybe in the next white game by
Young
and a lot more a lot more interesting
games I had in the nimsa or the Carlsbad
structure so some information there also
gained by Yan and by uh biting as well
uh a quiet day but definitely some
interesting takeaways from it what do
you guys think
yeah maybe we can pinpoint a couple of
key moments from the game because there
were some big decisions made you
mentioned the opening a niche the first
one uh Queens Gambit declined big
information there uh Jan he's played one
E4 he's played one D4 he knows what his
opponent's repertoire is going to be
for the tournaments and uh if we whiz
ahead it was perhaps uh later on you
mentioned that Yan was maybe caught by
surprise they were following your game
Anish and it was only later on here
after the bishop trade after a bit of
maneuvering uh where we thought perhaps
ding could have improved could have even
struck with B5 uh with white Under
Pressure
first key moment of the game
yeah definitely I think also the first
key moment uh there was probably one
before where Rihanna has decided to
follow you know my wrong footsteps
gaining nothing out of the opening but
certainly yes an important moment here
B5 or C5 uh but uh it's still lots of
interesting things happen later as well
after C5 I think this bishop takes the
7967 yeah was a small little potential
little turnaround there where ding got
some chances to go for the initiative
but uh yes after that I think uh Janus
played a reasonable reasonably
uh well and uh didn't look like ding had
something clear at any point
yeah yeah
feels like a small slip here Bishop
takes D7 we mentioned Knight to D4 white
would have been able to play on with
zero risk at all but uh yeah ding I
think maybe the most impressive move of
the whole game for me at least was
Knight takes D7 just having that on the
radar
um doing a little bit of calculation
realizing that that was the piece that
needed to be improved and um yeah
likewise for Yan the impressive move for
me was here it felt like white was under
serious pressure uh we went to a break
at this point thinking okay like is uh
doing the business maybe some tricks
with uh Knight takes V2 Knight takes A3
and uh yeah commentators curse I said no
nights on the rim Knight to A4 really
nice defensive move kicking the black
queen uh maybe in the wrong direction
and um yeah it was here that we started
repeating Knight B5 equally impressive
gotta say just uh
yeah just yeah I got some key squares
we take so much of this for granted when
these moments when one side is tiny bit
worse and then just finds two or three
accurate moves and makes the draw that's
what we're you so used to from these top
players and that is an incredible skill
so kudos to Yan holding his composure
and just uh you know hammering out
couple of accurate moves meat and
potatoes kind of game but you know Jan's
happy is up a point
yes indeed
[Music]
reinforce what you said about Knight A4
you know we've got this rule of no
Knights on the edge of the board but
sometimes you gotta break the rules and
top player like Jan he knows when to do
so and it's that's quite impressive
indeed we're looking at the scoreboard
here game three has concluded ladies and
gentlemen there are two draws game one
was a draw game two was a victory the
only victory of the match a black
victory for yanapam Nishi that is why he
has a one point lead as he leads the
match two points to one and tomorrow he
will have the black pieces in game four
David I mean he has one with the black
pieces that's not to say that Jan is
eagerly awaiting the game with the black
pieces I am eagerly awaiting uh what
ding will bring to the table will we see
H3 again somehow I don't think so what
about you David yeah I can guarantee
Daniel that we won't see H3 again
um ding not only lost with white uh in
game two of this match he also lost with
white against Yan in the candidates so
there is a bit of a mental block
um but either way I think ding should be
very happy with the way he played today
survived the black with no problems as
uh as you mentioned there and
if he switches us up even if he gets a
playable position out of the opening
with whites if he's not struggling from
an early stage like he was in game two
then I think great chances
um he will want to strike on the next uh
in the next game and yeah Jan
still ahead in the match but a long long
way to go
yeah I agree and certainly you know the
fact that he lost with white that's of
course a Pity but that said still the
white pieces are the ones where you try
to strike it'll match this long and
um that is the positive uh for ding
going into the next game but the
negative is that you know he's played H3
in the previous game that was maybe it
was that the best you know the best he
had his best weapon um if that is the
case then maybe he doesn't have any uh
great weapons in store ready for Yan so
I'm a little worried from that sense
because okay H3 is interesting it's nice
but it's only one H3
for A3 Yan will already be ready now my
question is does ding have something
interesting uh against the ants main
repair for does he have some interesting
idea in the tarash that young plays
maybe in the uh Catalan somewhere
because if he doesn't then it will be
difficult because Janu is playing so
well in such a good shape today also
demonstrated good form in the end you
know playing accurately in study was
position you're not going to beat him
empty-handed you need to have a weapon
and what the ding has a weapon I'm not
sure well we're about to find out
we are indeed we will find out to be
exact tomorrow as we look at the
schedule uh the game four starts at the
same time 2 A.M Pacific 5 a.m Eastern
and 11 p.m more civilized hour in uh
central European Standard time then of
course there are no more than two days
without a rest day so Friday will be
arrested followed by games over the
weekend on Saturday and Sunday all games
start at the same time at 2 A.M tomorrow
nepo as we're discussing we'll have
black pieces and on that note folks it
has come time for us to start wrapping
up um David Anish I'd like uh for you to
share your final thoughts on what we saw
today the shortest game of the match
thus far David I'll start with you your
kind of immediate conclusions uh firstly
I want to say sorry for jinxing it I've
joined you and it was a quick draw well
at least a short draw but uh yeah my
conclusions are that Ding is back I
loved seeing him at the board I think
that's the main takeaway he looked
focused he played made well and I think
promising signs for a hard-fought match
to come I was worried coming into today
that Ding wouldn't recover but the rest
did him good and uh yeah I'm optimistic
the rest of the match will be exciting
Anish ding is back do you agree with
that assertion did the game today
convince you the ding is in a better
State than he was after the loss
yeah I think you could say ding is back
I wouldn't uh write it with the capitals
like ding is back and like many
exclamation marks it's not this kind of
Dick's back it's like a dick is back you
know with the small regular font size
ding is back
but whether or not ding is back
that is what the fans are awaiting and I
think we are we might find out the next
game because then this kind of white
pieces that's where not only he might
get objective opportunities but it's
also the game the white pieces was where
your mindset is different so if heading
into today he probably didn't want to do
anything wild he was happy with the draw
but going to the next game he of course
wants to come back so he's got that
Spirit he's got the mindset and if he's
also got some opening weapon I think
there are chances he will actually be
back and uh of course we we want this
match to be exciting we want it to be
close and uh ding coming back would be a
huge news for this whole championship
it would indeed tomorrow is a huge game
folks ding we'll have the white pieces
another chance to prove himself and on
that note I'd like to thank uh my fellow
comments haters Grandmaster Anish Geary
Grandmaster David Howell a great
pleasure to commentate with you
um of course to our entire
amazingchess.com crew uh for another
Flawless production and of course to
everybody in the chat I think we had
something like 30 000 on Twitch alone we
have now hit over a million followers on
Twitch so a massive shout out to those
of you who take time out of your day to
watch our coverage and participate in
the chat uh you make this uh a magical
experience and on that note folks you
have been watching the 2023 fide World
Championship we will be back with game
four tomorrow bright and early but for
now have a great rest of your day this
was Master Daniel nerdinski Grant Master
anishikiri Grandmaster David Howell
saying goodbye from the feed 8 World
Championship we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]